madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers
collègues la
France est en
deuil 3 ans après Samuel
paatti un autre professeur un homme de
culture et de dialogue qui avait la
passion de transmettre la connaissance
Dominique Bernard est tombé sous les
coups d'un terroriste qu'il tentait
courageusement de
raisonner plus encore qu'un crime c'est
une profamation qui s'est commise à
haras car en France l'école est sacrée
elle est le sanctuaire du savoir où se
forme la
nation s'attaquer à l'école à travers un
professeur revient à défier notre
République tout entière notre modèle
humaniste de société que nous défendrons
toujours hier dans toutes les écoles de
France les élèves et leurs enseignants
ont observé une minute de
silence je ne doute pas que chacun
d'entre vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés ce soit associé à ce moment de
recueillement de civisme et d'unité mais
il me paraît important indispensable
même que la représentation nationale à
son tour rend hommage à Dominique ber
et Samuel
Patti je souhaite également que nous
exprimions notre solidarité à nos amis
belges et
suéois durement frappé hier à leur tour
par le terrorisme
islamiste pour nos deux professeurs pour
toutes les victimes du terrorisme en
Europe et ailleurs je vous demande
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés de bien vouloir observer une
minute de silence
je vous
remercie madame la Première ministre
vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés depuis vendredi dernier la
France est en
deuil au lycée Gambetta d'aras le
terrorisme islamiste frappé il a emporté
la vie d'un professeur de lettres
Dominique
Bernard sauvagement assassiné en
s'interposant face à l'agresseur pour
protéger les élèves et
l'école par ce geste il a été un rempart
de la
République avec vous au nom du
gouvernement je veux lui rendre
hommage dire ma solidarité à sa famille
et à ses proches
vendredi dernier lors de cette même
attaque un autre enseignant et deux
agents ont été
blessés nous sommes à leur côté et nous
sommes au côté des équipes des élèves et
des parents du lycée
Gambetta je veux aussi profiter de cet
instant pour dire ma solidarité et celle
de la France avec la Belgique et la
Suède après l'attentat qui a fait deux
morts hier à
Bruxelles mais mesdames et messieurs les
députés à tous les enseignants de France
à tous les élèves tous les parents tous
ceux qui sont attachés à nos valeurs
républicaines je le dis nous ne
renoncerons pas nous ne renoncerons pas
à faire vivre la transmission des
savoirs le débat d'idées et la liberté
de penser nous ne renoncerons pas à
former notre jeunesse à lui montrer le
cap de la République et de de la
citoyenneté nous ne renoncerons pas à
porter nos valeurs et défendre la
cohésion
nationale la France est Debout la
République est debout et si nous sommes
unis personne ne peut nous faire ployer
je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement la première
question va être posé par madame la
Présidente Panau pour le groupe la
France
insoumise
3 ans après l'acte terroriste islamiste
qui a ôté la vie à Samuel paatti
professeur d'histoire une fois de plus
un enseignant est assassiné une fois de
plus l'obscurantisme s'attaque au lieu
de la diffusion des lumières du savoir
une fois de plus le sens d'une religion
est dévoyé au contraire de ses valeurs
et une fois de plus le pays aura pu
constater l'engagement total de ses
enseignants pour ses
enfants Bernard a été assassiné et ses
collègues de travail blessés parce
qu'ils ont affronté eux-mêmes la mort
plutôt que de laisser les élèves en
danger aurély sa collègue décrit son
rapport au jeunes auquel il enseignait
les lettres tu étais là pour eux il
l'avait compris et se nourrissait en
désordre de ta passion contagieuse pour
la littérature de ta foi en l'homme des
espoirs que tu mettais en eux voici ce
que font les enseignants tous les jours
notre pensée émue va à l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui partageant la même
profession sont d'utant plus accablé
depuis vendredi nous leur disons votre
douleur est la nôtre notre gratitude est
totale comme notre affection et notre
respect face à la barbarie du meurtre il
est rude de continuer à garder foi en
l'humain mais voyant le courage de ces
enseignants nous savons que pour vaincre
la Terreur il est nécessaire d'éclairer
les chemins à ouvrir par les lumières de
la raison la transmission est le cœur
d'une société qui assume son devoir
devant l'avenir une société qui veut
continuer à vivre en commun sous une
même loi assurant la liberté de chacun
dans le respect de l'Autre c'est-à-dire
à faire République tel est l'enjeu
l'école est le lieu où se construit
cette œuvre qui libère l'esprit des
peurs de l'ignorance et de la nuit des
préjugés l'école a été visée vous devez
prendre madame la Première ministre
toutes les mesures pour protéger les
personnels et les élèves mais surtout
l'école doit continuer à œuvrer à
l'émancipation de tous les citoyens pour
cela elle doit être dotée de tous les
moyens nécessaires allez-vous comme le
demandent les enseignants recruter tous
les personnels essentiels à
l'encadrement des élèves don un appu in
merci beaucoup la parole est à madame la
Première
[Musique]
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Mathilde
panneau c'est avec gravité que je veux
vous répondre
aujourd'hui vous avez rendu hommage à
Dominique
Bernard cet hommage nous le devons à ce
professeur de lettes tomberé comme
Samuel paatti avant lui sous les coups
du terrorisme
islamiste j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer et j'aurai l'occasion d'en
dire davantage dans les minutes qui
viennent madame la Présidente Panau je
veux rendre hommage également aux
victimes de l'attaque terroriste qui a
frappé Bruxelles hier
je veux rendre hommage enfin aux
victimes des attentats barbares qui ont
frappé Israël des attentats terroristes
commis par un groupe terroriste le
Hamas
un groupe que vous refusez de qualifier
comme tel un groupe que certains parmi
vous ont même osé qualifier de mouvement
de
résistance depuis le 7
octobre les voix de la France insoumises
manquent à la condamnation unanime de la
barbarie terroriste elle manque à
l'unité nationale vous avez tenté de
justifier vos ambiguités mais ce matin
la réalité est apparue au grand jour la
justice est saisie elle tranchera mais
en entendant ses propos je pense à ces
jeunes tués lors d'une fête je pense à
ces massacres dans les kibuts de Berry
et de karaza je pense à ces femmes ces
hommes ces personnes ces personnes âgées
et ces enfants enlevés pour vous ce ne
sont pas des actes terroristes pour moi
vous vous excluez du champ républicain
je
merci
beaucoup merci madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier fallorni pour le groupe
démocrate
merci
présid Dominique Bernard était
professeur de lettres il aimait les
livres et il aimait les mots à ses
élèves il aimait leur apprendre les mots
comme on offre un présent pour leur
construire un avenir à ses élèves il
aimait leur apprendre les mots car il
savait que ce sont des joyaux de
connaissance et de
tolérance vendredi dernier Dominique
Bernard est mort
d'enseigné assassiné par la barbarie du
terroriste
islamiste face à ces tragédies et à leur
répétition les mots peuvent désormais
nous sembler usés et
unutile pourtant je me refuse d'y
renoncer et je veux donc dire ici et
avec vous aux famillees des victimes à
tous les enseignants de France et à tous
les agents de l'éducation nationale je
veux leur dire tout notre soutien et
toute notre
affection
on ne prostitue pas impunément les mots
écrivait Albert Camu cette phrase
résonne aujourd'hui comme un
avertissement à tous ceux qui hurlent
offense quand vous parlez seulement de
liberté d'expression à tous ceux qui
hurlent islamophobie quand vous défendez
simplement la
laïcité elle raisonne comme un
avertissement à ceux qui trahissent les
mots par bêtis par fanatisme cyisme à
ceux pour qui il est visiblement plus
facile de crier police fasciste que de
dire Hamas
terroriste allez-y mon cher collègue
hier soir encore 3 ans après
l'assassinat de son frère
Samuel c'est Michel Paty qui a su
trouver les mots les plus justes je vous
remercie de conclure crime de guerre ou
crime contre l'humanité terrorisme ou
décapitation écoutons madame madame Paty
quand elle nous dit qu'après ces motsl N
a pas de en France il y a un point la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel ministre
de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse faut couper le chrono quand
est merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Olivier fallorni vendredi le
terrorisme islamiste s'en est pris à
nouveau à notre école vendredi le
terrorisme islamiste a assassiné
Dominique
Bernard vendredi ils ont frappé mais
notre école reste debout
elle reste debout à aras où je veux
saluer l'immense courage l'absolu
dignité et l'admirable ténacité de la
communauté
enseignante comme partout en France
notre communauté éducative fait face
elle fait bloc à nous de lui dire
aujourd'hui toute notre reconnaissance
et toute notre admiration mesdames et
messieurs la Nation toute entière est
meurtrie par l'assassinat de Dominique
Bernard 3 ans après Samuel Patis et la
barbarie abjecte du terrorisme islamiste
qui frappe à nouveau ce qu'on voulu
attaquer les terroriste c'est au fond
notre école à la française parce que
notre école est un obstacle ultime à
leur funestre projet je le dis les
islamistes veulent tenir éloignés du
savoir le plus grand nombre pour imposer
leur obscurantisme notre école à la
française elle défend la démocratisation
du savoir pour
tous les islamistes
ils veulent soumettre les femmes notre
école accueille toutes les petites
filles de France avec tous les petits
garçons de France pour leur transmettre
le
savoir les islamistes veulent imposer le
règne de la religion à l'école nous
imposons celui de la République et de la
laïcité dans toutes les écoles de
France alors oui nous continuerons à
défendre ces valeurs qui ne sont pas des
concepts abstraits qui sont des combats
de tous les jours qui doivent être
défendus par chacune et chacun d'entre
nous comme vous monsieur le député je
veux dénoncer celles et ceux qui
manquent dans ce combat mais je veux
aussi relever qu'hier qu'aujourd'hui et
que dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent les Français continueront à
faire face et à faire bloc derrière
leurs enseignants et derrière leur
monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Fabien
Roussel pour le groupe
GDR madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre Dominique Bernard
professeur de français a été assassiné
par un terroriste islamiste dans son
lycée trois autres collègues qui ont
tout fait comme lui pour protéger nos
enfants sont blessés 3 ans après
l'assassinat barbare de Samuel paatti
encore une fois la République est
attaqué meurtri encore une fois l'école
de la République ceux qui la font vivre
sont pris pour cible et c'est toute la
nation qui est endeuillée au nom des
députés communistes et du groupe GDR
nous nous inclinons
pour honorer leur mémoire leur bravoure
et pour rendre hommage le cœur serré à
toute une profession qui exerce le plus
beau métier du monde hier lors de la
minute de silence à saintamant les EAU
j'ai entendu les craintes mesurer les
peurs recueillli la souffrance des
enseignants des parents d'élèves des
enfants nos enfants il faut les rassurer
si l'école publique laïque est ciblée
c'est bien parce qu'elle est le meilleur
rempart contre l'obsc antisme c'est
parce qu'elle développe l'esprit
critique face au dogmatisme alors ce
nouveau crime nous oblige une nouvelle
fois nous unir et d'une seule voix à
condamné le terrorisme et la barbarie
qui frappe nos écoles rien ne peut les
justifier ni ici ni ailleurs cela nous
oblige aussi à avoir une réponse à la
hauteur de cette attaque à dire au
effort que nous ne combattrons pas la
haine par la haine mais par le droit et
la justice à dire ensemble ici que nous
ne cèderons pas à la peur pas plus qu'à
la division de nos concitoyens selon
leur religion ou leur origine au
contraire la plus belle et la plus forte
des réponses c'est de donner tous les
moyens à nos enseignants à notre école
publique pour qu'elle puisse remplir
totalement sa mission émancipatrice son
enseignement universaliste et humaniste
alors madame la Première ministre les
enseignants attendent tellement
tellement de l'État quel moyen
entendez-vous mettre au
de l'école de la République je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
gabrielal ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Fabien Roussel nos 12
millions d'élèves en France ont une
chance inouie pouvoir compter sur 860000
enseignants à leur côté 860000
enseignants et toute la communauté
éducative autour d'eux qui ont une
vocation démocratiser avoir leur
permettre à chacun de s'élever de briser
les destins écrits par avance c'est ça
la vocation des enseignants cette
vocation il la pousse chaque jour à son
maximum et je le dis à haras leur
réaction a été absolument exemplaire
pour mettre à l'abri et protéger leurs
élèves alors même qu'il ne devrait pas
être confronté à ces situations la
vocation d'un enseignant c'est de sauver
des vies par la pédagogie pas en se
mettant entre un terroriste et des
élèves notre responsabilité c'est donc
de leur apporter tous les les moyens
pour qu'il se sente et qu'il soit en
sécurité en sécurité physique dans des
bâtiments sécurisés on doit toujours
être plus en sécurité dans une école
qu'à l'extérieur d'une école en sécurité
intellectuelle à l'heure où un
enseignant sur deux déclare s'être déjà
autocensuré dans ses enseignements par
crainte de réaction ou de représaill
notamment sur les questions de laïcité
notre responsabilité c'est d'être au
rendez-vous de cette attente de sécurité
parce que la peur d'enseigner c'est un
poison mortel pour notre école et c'est
ce que veulent les terroristes ils
veulent détruire notre école parce
qu'elle ne correspond pas à leur projet
ils veulent dégoûter les enseignants
enenseignés dégoûter les élèves leur
faire peur et donc notre responsabilité
c'est d'être absolument au rendez-vous
de cette sécurité j'ai passé toute la
soirée de vendredi encore toute la
matinée aujourd'hui avec les
organisations syndicales des enseignants
je serai demain avec les représentants
des collectivités locales notamment sur
la question de la sécurisation de nos
bâtiments beaucoup a été fait ces
dernières années beaucoup reste encore à
faire en lien avec elle et avec eux nous
devons aussi continuer à avancer sur
cette question de la transmission et de
la lutte contre l'autocensure et je le
dis nous aurons besoin là aussi d'une
très grande unité des forces politiques
derrière ce projet qui est un projet qui
n'est pas partisan au politique qui est
tout simplement le projet de la
République je vous remci je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame
Jacqueline Maquet pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre chers
collègues la République a été frappée au
cœur à haras dans cette hémicycle où
nous incarnons la nation je tiens à
rendre un hommage solennel à Dominique
Bernard qui par son sacrifice a sauvé de
nombreuses vies un homme rare un
professeur exceptionnel je pense
également à David à Jacques gravement
blessé à Christian et au proviseurs qui
ont fait preuve d'une bravoure hors
norme je tiens à saluer l'ensemble des
personnels du du collège du lycée
Gambetta qui ont protégé leurs élèves
nos enfants je tiens aussi à exprimer
notre gratitude au service de sécurité
de secours nos policiers étaient sur les
lieux en seulement 4 minutes mettant fin
au carnage nos soignants ont pris en
charge d'AVI des Jacques et continue
d'accompagner psychologiquement les
élèves et la communauté éducative merci
à eux 3 ans après Samuel pati le
terrorisme islamiste tente à nouveau de
nous diviser en s'attaquant à notre cole
passeuse de nos valeurs républicaines
face à ce cancer qui menace notre
cohésion notre réponse doit être ferme
Unis déterminé au-delà de nos émotions
profondes de notre colère légitime et de
notre aspiration à la justice il est de
notre responsabilité de poser les
questions essentielles pour l'avenir de
notre pays madame la Première ministre
quel engagement prenez-vous pour
protéger notre jeunesse et nos
enseignants face à l'obscurantisme
comment mieux armer notre répuique face
à cet ennemi assidieux notre devoir est
d'agir avec détermination et
clairvoyance nous devons à nos
concitoyens aux victimes et à leurs
familles non pas seulement des paroles
mais des actes forts et concrets pour
garantir la péritnité de notre modèle
républicain je vous remercie ma cher
collègue la parole est à madame la
Première
ministre merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Jacqueline
Maquet
vendredi dernier au lycée Gambetta
d'aras dans votre circonscription madame
la députée le terrorisme islamiste a
frappé emportant la vie de Dominique
Bernard blessant un autre enseignant et
deux agents mes premières pensées V vont
aux victimes à leur familles leurs
proches et leurs collègues comme le
président de la République dès vendredi
à haras je tenais une nouvelle fois à
leur dire toute ma solidarité mon
soutien et ce de mon gouvernement nous
sommes avec eux nous resterons avec eux
je mesure les inquiétudes des
enseignants des élèves et des parents
ces derniers jours les inquiétudes des
Français choqués par cette attaque
sauvage préoccupé par la situation
internationale et par l'attaque
terroriste hier à
Bruxell madame la députée maqué face aux
inquiétudes et aux menac
vous demandez des actes forts et des
réponses fermes vous avez raison comme
l'a dit le président de la républi nous
serons
impitoyables nous avons pris des mesures
immédiates pour renforcer la sécurité du
territoire et de nos écoles vendredi
soir j'ai réhaussé la posture Vig pirate
au niveau urgence attentat le plus haut
niveau 10000 policiers et gendarmes sont
mobilisés le président de la République
a décidé d'engager 7000 militaires dans
l'opération sentinelle la sécurité aux
abords des écoles a été renforcée avec
notamment le déploiement de personnel de
prévention et de sécurité de l'éducation
nationale cela s'ajoute à des
investissements de long terme au côté
des collectivités pour la sécurité des
écoles nous poursuivons notre lutte
intraitable contre le terrorisme les
services de renseignement sont mobilisés
leur action est déterminante et je veux
les saluer
nous accélérons pour expulser les
étrangers radicalisés dès vendredi à la
suite d'une réunion de sécurité autour
du président de la République le
ministre de l'Intérieur a demandé au
préfet de réexaminer au cas par cas
l'expulsion immédiate ou le retrait du
titre de séjour des étrangers
radicalisés madame la députée 3 ans
pratiquement jour pour jour après
l'assassinat sauvage de Samuel Patti
c'est à nouveau une école qui est prise
pour cible cela n'a rien d'anodin
l'école c'est la transmission des
savoirs c'est l'apprentissage de la
liberté c'est le creusé de la
citoyenneté et de la laïcité l'école
c'est
l'émancipation c'est notre jeunesse qui
se forme qui grandit qui choisit sa vie
s'en prendre aux enseignants c'est s'en
prendre à notre modèle républicain alors
je le dis fermement nous serons là pour
protéger les Français nous serons là
pour protéger la République nous
resterons Unis rassemblé autour de nos
valeurs l'obscurantisme et la terreur ne
l'emporteront jamais je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
Première ministre madame la députée
merci madame la Première ministre merci
beaucoup je vous
remci la parole s'il vous
plaît la parole est à monsieur le
Président Marle pour le groupe les
républicains Mame la première ministre
une fois de plus une fois de
le terrorisme islamiste a frappé notre
pays une fois de plus 3 ans après la
mort de Samuel paatti nous voilà réduit
à pleurer la disparition d'un enseignant
admirable de courage Dominique Bernard
que la République aurait dû protéger en
disant la France a pleuré 273 victimes
du terrorisme islamique quand la France
sortira-t-elle du dénis de réalité quand
la France prendra-t-elle enfin la mesure
de la gravité de la crise ne sommes-nous
là que pour nous lever et compter les
minutes de silence non nous sommes ici
pour doter pour donner à la France les
moyens d'agir face à cette barbarie
c'est un combat digne de notre histoire
et de nos valeurs non monsieur Darmanin
votre texte n'aurait rien empêché il
aurait juste permis que les terroristes
d'aras soi le 12000 destinataire d'une
TF non
exécuté mais
failiter l'expulsion des individus
dangereux avant qu'il ne passe à l'acte
quand allez-vous admettre que ce n'est
pas en changeant tro alinéas dans le
code de séjour des étrangers que nous
allons reprendre le contrôle de notre
politique
migratoire parce qu'en fait ce n'est
plus la loi qui
décide ce n'est pas le ministre qui
décide tous ceux qui sont passés par le
ministère de l'Intérieur le savent en
matière d'ex des étrangers c'est le juge
qui a le dernier mot c'est le juge qui
sous couvert d'interpréter les traités
ordonne que tant d'qtf soit relâché dans
la nature c'est le juge qui crée les
obligations nouvelles pour nous empêcher
d'expulser obligations qui s'imposent à
leur présentation nationale et B fou la
volonté du peuple souverain alors madame
la Première ministre face à cette
impuissance organisée la seule réponse
c'est de changer la constitution
changeons la Constitution pour permettre
à la France de retrouver souveré et
ronnons la parole au peuple
françaisadop par réérend voilci monsieur
le Président merci beaucoup la parole
est à madame la Première
[Applaudissements]
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président
marlex s'il vous
plaît face au terrorisme islamiste qui a
frappé notre pays vendredi nous avons le
d'être à la
hauteur être à la hauteur c'est ne rien
céder à la haine faire bloc et faire
vivre notre cohésion nationale et notre
unité mais être à la hauteur c'est aussi
lutter fermement contre le terrorisme
aujourd'hui la menace est forte
l'attentat hier à Bruxelles nous le
rappelle nous avons pris des mesures
immédiates pour assurer la sécurité des
Français notamment en rehaussant la
posture Vigi pirate au niveau urgence
attentat nous serons impitoyables avec
notamment une attention particulière
pour les étrangers radicalisés 900 ont
déjà été expulsés depuis 2017 nous avons
intensifié l'examin de la situation des
étrangers connu pour islamisme radical
il n'y a pas de place en France pour
ceux qui attaquent la
République Monsieur le Président marlex
il y a un point sur lequel nous sommes
d'accord nous devons chaque fois que
c'est nécessaire faire évoluer notre
droit et nos pratiques et nous n devons
le faire rapidement comme vous je crois
que notre système d'asile a besoin
d'être réformé et que nous devons mieux
maîtriser nos flux migratoire nous
devons mieux lutter contre l'immigration
illégale expulser plus facilement les
individus en situations irrégulière
retirer les titres de séjour des
étrangers en situation régulière qui
constituent une menace pour notre pays
ce sont certains des objectif du projet
de loi immigration porté par le ministre
de l'Intérieur sur lequel nous voulons
continuer à travailler avec vous et avec
tous ceux qui veulent répondre au défis
migratoires un projet de loi que nous
sommes donc prêts à faire évoluer en
prenant toutes les mesures utiles et
efficaces efficacité fermeté et cohésion
nationale voilà le sens de la politique
que nous portons voilà nous comment nous
apporterons des réponses au défis devant
nous sans jamais rien céder sur nos
valeurs je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la Première
ministre la parole est à Madame
Francesca paschini pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'éducation nationale en toute sincérité
je ne sais pas si c'est la maman
l'enseignante ou la députée qui
s'exprime lorsque j'ai appris le décès
du Professeur Bernard lorsque j'ai
appris qu'un nouvel attentat terroriste
avait frappé l'école j'ai eu peur en
tant que maman je me suis sentie
impuissante en tant qu'élu et je me suis
sentie meurtrie en tant ancienne
enseignante c'est le ressenti de tous
ceux qui sont professeurs par mécanisme
de défense mon cerveau a refusé les
images terribles que nous présentaient
les médias dans ma tête tournait plutôt
en boucle celle du compagnon d'Agnès
Lassalle dansant l'heure de ses
funérailles quelle leçon il nous avait
donné à tous en offrant une dernière
danse à celle qu'il chérissait il avait
sans peut-être le savoir ni le vouloir
mis en scène la parfaite allégorie de
l'enseignement il avait donné le tempo
la mesure et la dynamique rejoint par
d'autres ils avaient porté
collectivement un unique message
d'espoir d'amour et de résilience le
travail quotidien de la communauté
éducative c'est celui-là grâce à eux le
lieu d'émancipation qui l'école sera
toujours synonyme de liberté monsieur le
ministre les enseignants mènent un noble
combat au quotidien nous devons faire en
sorte que les valeurs que portaient
Monsieur paaty Madame Lassal et Monsieur
Bernard fleurissent au sein de l' é cela
n'est possible que si nous en faisons
notre priorité et allons tous dans la
même direction ma question est donc la
suivante comment comptez-vous
accompagner épauler et rassurer la
communauté éducative en deuiller depuis
3 ans des enseignants meurent combien de
temps faudra-t-il pour en tirer une
leçon je vous remercie ma chère collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Atal
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la
jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Francesca
Pasquini je le disais à l'instant
réponse à Fabien Roussel la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre c'est
d'être à la hauteur des attentes des
enseignants et de leurs besoins pour
leur permettre toujours d'exercer la
mission qui est la leheure celle de
transmettre à nos enfants dans des
conditions de sécurité qui leur sont d
vous savez des samedi soir j'ai tenu à
réunir les députés membres des
commissions des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation de l'Assemblée nationale
et du Sénat précisément pour faire un
point avec vous sur ce sujet-là ce que
je veux dire d'abord madame la député
c'est qu'à la à la suite de chaque
attaque terroriste dans notre pays les
gouvernements qui se sont succédés et
compris avant 2017 d'ailleurs ont pris
des mesures pour renforcer la sécurité
de nos établissements ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce qui a probablement
permis d'éviter un carnage absolu à
haras c'est l'équipement de cet
établissement d'un plan de mise en
sûreté et je le dis ici devant vous la
réaction des équipes de direction la
réaction des enseignants a été
absolument exemplaire pour mettre tous
les élèves à l'abri notamment parce
qu'il disposait de ses équipements et de
ses formations l'enjeu maintenant c'est
de garantir que partout en France dans
tous nos établissements scolaires dans
toutes nos écoles les équipes puissent
travailler en sérénité en sachant
qu'elles sont protégées c'est l'enjeu de
la réunion que j'aurai demain avec les
associations d'élus précisément pour
faire le point avec elle un audit avait
été réalisé en 2015 sur l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires il s'agit de
mesurer les efforts qui ont été réalisés
il y en a eu depuis 2017 nous avons
investi 100 millions d'euros sur la
sécurisation des bâtiments publics et
notamment des écoles mais évidemment
qu'il faut aller plus loin je suis saisi
comme vous je crois comme des élus des
parlementaires qui me saisissent
d'établissements scolaires de lycées ou
de collèges pour lesquels il manque des
dispositifs de sécurisation l'enjeu
c'est que nous avancions rapidement avec
les collectivités territoriales pour
être au rendez-vous de l'attente absolue
et de notre responsabilité absolue qui
est celle de protéger la communauté
éducative qui a besoin de protection et
de sécurité pour faire son travail
accomir sa missionoup monsieur le
ministre merci
beaucoup madame Pasini merci pour votre
réponse monsieur le ministre ce qui a
évité un carnage à haras c'est aussi
qu'un enseignant s'est entreposé entre
les élèves et un
terroriste je vous
remercie la parole est à madame la
Présidente roche pour le groupe
horizon merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît nos professeurs
sont là pour nous aider à apprendre pour
nous faire grandir pas pour risquer leur
vie s'attaquer aux écoles c'est pas
normal c'est inadmissible c'est nul nous
vivons dans un pays en paix on ne peut
pas tolérer ça encore moins de la part
d'un ancien élève du lycée ces mots
simples N sont pas les miens ils sont
ceux de jeunes lycéens en filièrees
professionnell qui ont organisé hier
dans ma circonscription avec l'aide de
leur professeur d'histoire géographie et
de sciences une cérémonie de
recueillement à la mémoire de Dominique
Bernard et de Samuel paatti les
autorités présentes ont entendu leurs
mots ils ont entendu leur dilemme aussi
leur silence comme des fellures face à à
l'innommable face à la barbarie face à
la marche d'un monde au repère si
difficile à comprendre ils ont rendu
hommage comme nous venons de le faire à
Bernard à Samuel Patti avec la
conscience qu'à travers leur assassinat
c'est la communauté nationale qui est
visée c'est toute la République qui est
attaqué avec ce qu'elle porte
l'émancipation par les savoirs
l'affranchissement des dogmes la liberté
de conscience le droit d'apprendre la
formation de l'esprit critique mais ce
que j'ai retenu de plus fort dans cette
séquence c'est un cri fut-il sourd
fut-il défu laissez-nous apprendre
laissez-nous grandir nous aurons perdu
si nous ne pouvons plus faire germer ces
graines de voir l'hydroterroriste qui a
encore frappé Bruxelles hier soir
voudrait nous enfermer dans l'ignorance
les enfermer dans l'ignorance et nous
empêcher aussi de penser de vibrer de
partager de fréquenter des écoles des
salles de spectacles des stades d'être
nous et de savoir le transmettre à nos
enfants d'être légitime à le faire et de
ne jamais s'autocensurer aussi Monsieur
le Ministre la question est à la fois
simple et immense comment aider tous les
jeunes de France et comment appuyer
leurs enseignants à mettre des mots sur
ces drames pour savoir les surmonter
encore plus fort comment accompagner
soutenir toute la communauté éducative
pour que notre école continue à être le
creuser de notre République je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel hatal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la présidente Isabelle roche vous avez
rappelé à travers vos mots et ce d'élèv
de votre circonscription ce qui est la
mission absolue de l'école former des
républicains et des citoyens éclairé ce
qui implique qu'y compris dans des
drames tels que celui que nous avons
vécu l'école soit au rendez-vous pour
accueillir les élèves et pour mettre des
mots sur ce qu'il s'est passé pour
échanger avec eux j'ai ressenti quand
j'ai réuni les organisations
représentatives des enseignants vendredi
soir le besoin de la communauté
enseignante et plus globalement des
personnels de l'école de bénéficier d'un
temps dédié pour pouvoir préparer ce
retour des élèves pour pouvoir porter le
deuil aussi parce qu'il pèse le plus
lourd sur nos enseignants qui ont perdu
l'un des l'un des leurs et pour pouvoir
préparer le retour des élèves et
préparer ensemble les meilleurs mots
pour les accueillir et répondre à leurs
questions qui sont nombreuses ce temps
leur avait manqué il y a 3 ans après
l'assassinat de Samuel pati j'ai tenu à
ce qu'il puisse en disposer après
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard je me
suis rendu hier dans un établissement
dans plusieurs établissements scolaires
et j'ai pe mesurer que ce temps avait
été utile qu' avait permis aux
enseignants de mettre ensemble les mots
sur ce qu'il s'est passé pour accueillir
leurs élèves je me suis rendu avec la
première ministre au collège du bois
d'ulne pour le temps d'hommage et de
recueillement qui s'est qui s'est tenu
partout en France nous avons échangé
avec les enseignants là aussi vous posez
la question très concrète de ce qui est
mis en place pour les soutenir notamment
psychologiquement dans cette épreuve à
la demande des enseignants j'ai réactivé
les dispositifs d'écoute et
d'accompagnement qui avaient été mis en
place au moment de l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti notamment une cellule
nationale avec des psychologues 24 he
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 mais également des
cellules d'écoute académique au plus
près des enseignants pour les
accompagner mais c'est tout au long de
l'année et c'est fondamentalement que
nous devons accompagner les enseignants
dans leur mission qui est de former des
républicains et des citoyens éclairés et
malheureusement il est beaucoup
d'endroits aujourd'hui où il peineent à
le faire parce que les pressions sont
fortes parce que les coups de bouttoir
sont fortes et vous pouvez compter sur
ma détermination pour être au
rendez-vous de cette responsabilité
absolue merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à madame la
Présidente Le Pen pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre après le
nouveau drame que vient de vivre notre
pays permettez-moi une pensée pour les
proches de Dominique Bernard ainsi que
pour les blessés dont le courageux
employé qui s'est dressé face à la
barbarie mais aussi à l'égard des
professeurs angoissé d'être devenus des
cibles mais madame la Première ministre
nous sommes législateurs comptable de
l'efficacité des réponses apportées à
ces drames
alors pourquoi annoncer l'expulsion des
étrangers inscrits au fsprt pardon
maintenant et pas avant alors que sur 25
attentats depuis 2017 la moitié était le
fait d'étranger dont 3/4 de surcroix
clandestin et pour beaucoup quasiment la
moitié suivie pour fondamentalisme
islamique pourquoi ne pas expulser tous
les étrangers islamistes qu'ils soi en
situation légale ou illégal car ils sont
avant tout des ennemis de la
France pourquoi ne pas étendre expulsion
à ceux qui ont commis des crimes et des
délites graves à leur sortie de prison
islamistes criminels et délinquants
qu'est-ce qui justifie de garder ces
personnes sur notre
sol pourquoi en trompant les Français se
servir de l'attentat terroriste d'aras
pour vendre votre future loi d'immigra
sur l'immigration en faisant croire que
le droit actuel ne nous permettrait pas
d'expulser le terroriste en question au
motif qu'il est arrivé et en France
avant 13 ans il a résidé alors que que
le droit vous permettait évidemment de
le faire comme l'indique le plus
clairement du monde l'article 6313 du
cza article d'ailleurs totalement
compatible avec l'article 33 aléa 2 de
la Convention de Genève relative au
statut des réfugiés pour résumer
pourquoi faire croire que votre
incapacité à juguler le fondamentalisme
islamiste est la conséquence des lois
que vous auriez d'ailleurs pu changer
depuis 6 ans alors que votre impuissance
est avant tout la conséquence de votre
absence de volonté réelle et
probablement d'une forme de crainte qui
vous empêche de lutter efficacement
contre les idéologies islamistes qui se
répandent et tuent dans notre
pays la parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la Présidente Marine Le Pen vendredi
dernier un professeur de lettres du
lycée gambeta d'aras Dominique Bernard a
été sauvage assassiné par un terroriste
islamiste en écho tragique à
l'assassinat de Samuel paatti il y a 3
ans ces moment ces moments s'il vous
plaît ces moments graves sont
révélateurs il nous
oblige il nous oblige d'abord à un peu
de dignité madame la Présidente Le Pen
depuis 2022 à chaque crise vous vous
êtes illustré par votre silence
aujourd'hui naturel revient au Galot
alors que la France est en deuil alors
que l'école est touchée alors qu'un
enseignant est mort vous vous lancez
dans des polémiques politiciennes vous
jetez des des anathèmes vous multipliez
les mises en cause alors que le
terrorisme frappe et que la situation
internationale est préoccupante vous
refusez ce matin même explicitement
l'unité de notre pays madame la
Présidente Le Pen dans les moments
graves je crois pour ma part dans la
cohésion nationale et dans l'action et
avec mon gouvernement j'y suis
déterminé face aux menaces qui pèent sur
notre pays nous sommes fermes fermes
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme et
depuis 2017 nous avons accordé des
moyens inédit à nos services de
renseignement et à notre justice des
moyens qui ont permis de déjouer 43
attentats depuis 6 ans ferme dès le 7
octobre et l'attaque terroriste contre
Israël en renfor la sécurité des lieux
sensibles et en procédant à
l'interpellation de plus de 100
individus en lien direct avec des actes
antisémiste ou d'apologie du terrorisme
ferme et réactif pour la sécurité de nos
écoles dès vendredi j'ai réhaussé la
posture vigip pirate la sécurité des
écoles a été renforcée et sur décision
du Président de la République 7000
militaires ont été mobilisés dans le
cadre de l'opération sentinelle ferme
face à l'immigration illégale et face
aux étr
radicalisé sur notre territoire en 6 ans
madame la Présidente Le Pen plus de 900
étrangers fichés au fsprt ont été
expulsés donc quand nous pouvons les
expulser nous le faisons être ferme
enfin c'est renforcer notre arsenal
juridique etlever les freins législatifs
à l'expulsion des étrangers qui
représentent une menace pour notre pays
c'est l'un des objectifs du projet de
loi immigration que porte le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin quand certains pensent
polémique je veux pour ma part dire mon
soutien aux agents de nos servic de
renseignement aux enquêteurs à nos
policiers à nos gendarmes à nos
militaires mobilisés dans la lutte
contre le
terrorisme et devant vous une nouvelle
fois je l'affirme face au drame notre
force c'est notre unité c'est le respect
de nos valeurs républicaines c'est la
cohésion na avec mon gouvernement nous
irons je vouserci merci beaucoup madame
la Première
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
Président Houlier pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'agresse au ministre de l'Intérieur et
des outr ma monsieur le ministre ce
vendredi 13 octobre 3 ans après le
meurtre de Samuel pati un autre
professeur est tombé sous les coups de
couteau d'un terroriste islamiste et je
vais avoir une pensée aujourd'hui pour
Dominique Bernard ses collègues c'est
proches sa famille et toute la
communauté éducative je veux aussi avoir
une pensée pour nos amis belges et
suédois frappé par un attentat
terroriste hier soir je veux saluer en
tant que président de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement le
travail des services des services qui
empêchent la commission d'attentat comme
cela vient d'être dit sur notre
territoire national des services qui en
dépit des critiques de certains
résistent et apporte toute la sécurité
nécessaire à la population c'est toute
l'assemblée nationale qui doit les
soutenir vous avez interrogé sur les
moyens de ces services qui ont certaines
dispositions en matière d'algorithme
pour la prévention du terrorisme
d'ailleurs la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement proposera de les
élargir pour ce qui concerne l'ingérance
avez-vous de nouvelles propositions pour
qu'ils puisse agir efficacement vous
avez interrogé en matière d'immigration
sur une loi que nous préparons et je
veux rappeler une évidence les
travailleurs n'ont pas à payer les pets
cassé pour les délinquants notre projet
il est radical sur tous les aspects
radical en matière de justice parce
qu'il propose de régulariser les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
radical en matière de fermeté pour
expulser ceux qui n'ont rien à faire sur
notre sol et personne n'a de temps à
perdre et certainement pas nos
concitoyens lever des réserves d'ordre
publici double peine retrait ou non
renouvellement des titres pour non
respect des valeurs de la République
voilà des propositions que nous faisons
et donc que nous sommes empêchés
d'adopter par faute de certains de nos
collègues sur ces bancs qui se refusent
à ce que nous les examinions alors
Monsieur le Ministre ma question est
simple quand pourrons-nous examiner ces
dispositions allez-vous accélérer le
calendrier et allez-vous nous permettre
d'examiner les moyens que certains vous
réclament notamment à droite mais qu'il
se priv de nous permettre d'examiner
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président la
parole est à Monsieur Géral ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
outr mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
sachaouer merci d'avoir remercié les
agents de la DGSI qui
méticulleusement courageusement parfois
mépris de leur vie travaill pour la
sécurité des Français déjou tous les
mois des attentats au sol national et
merci de le souligner quand les moments
sont difficiles pour toute la France du
travail exemplaire des policiers de la
DGSI merci monsieur le Président de
souigner aussi les moyens que nous leur
donnons vous la majorité parlementaire
et je veux dire à Madame Le Pen que la
prochaine fois elle ferait mieux de
voter les dispositions de les lois
renseignement plutôt que de pleurer
faussement pour vivre des problèmes et
oui monsieur le Président veut-on oui ou
non veut-on oui ou non lever les
réserves d'entre publi qui ont été
installé depuis plus de 15 ans pour
expulser tous les délinquants étrangers
que la loi empêche auourd'hui d'expulser
la réponse est oui c'est dans la loi
immigration veut-on obliger tous les
étrangers qui arrivent sur le sol
national à apprendre à parler français
la réponse est oui c'est dans la loi
immigration veut-on permettre au
ministre de l'Intérieur de retirer un
titre de séjour pour quelqu'un qui ne
respecte pas les valeurs de la
République oui c'est dans le texte
immigration veut-on finalement régler
les problèmes d'intégration et
d'immigration en France pour expulser
les délinquants étrangers pour ne pas
laisser simplement au juges le soin de
le faire mais pour laisser au
législateur monsieur marlex de prendre
ses responsabilités dans un texte de loi
que vous avez vous-même installé quand
vous étiez en
responsabilité monsieur marlex il doit
avoir des limites me semble-t-il au
manque de responsabilité modifier la
Constitution si vous le souhaitez dans 3
ans mais donnez aujourd'hui les moyens
au préfet au ministre de l'Intérieur de
protéger les
Français je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur le s'il vous
plaît la parole est à monsieur le
Président valallot pour le groupe
socialiste madame la Première ministre 3
ans après Samuel pati Dominique Bernard
professeur de lettrre a été assassiné
par un terroriste islamiste je veux dire
ici l'horreur que cela nous inspire nous
pensons à lui à ses proches au blessés
aux élèves du lycée Gambetta nous
pensons à cet instant à nos professeurs
et de l'éducation meurtrie par ce drame
Dominique Bernard a aujourd'hui un
visage celui de la France et par la voix
de ses collègues de ses élèves nous
savons le professeur aimé qu'il était le
pédagogue passionné le ferru de culture
et d'éducation populaire l'homme
attentif aux autres et généreux de
lui-même le meilleur de l'homme le
meilleur de l'école celle qui instruit
celle qui élève les esprits qui cherch
la vérité qui rend libre madame la
Première ministre notre dev voir et de
faire bloc et parce que les écoles
doivent rester l'asile inviolable les
querelles des hommes ne pénètre pas nous
refusons qu'elle soit un champ de
bataille tenons-nous auprès de nos
enseignants qui accomplissent temps et
auxquels on demande toujours plus ils ne
règleront pas à eux seuls les mots de
notre temps et de notre société ne le
rons pas responsable de tout et
donnonsleur les moyens d'accomplir leurs
missions éminentes et qu'ils
accomplissent avec dévouement chaque
jour
ne sons pas au procès facile de l'école
prétendument impuissante dont le
quotidien se régale mais ne se grandit
pas entendons leurs inquiétudes leurs
peur aussi parce qu'ils se savent
désormais être des cibles entendons
leurs attentes leurs difficultés leurs
incompréhensions parfois répondons à nos
professeurs oui nous vous entendons
reprenons le fil commencé d'être tissé
après les attentat de Charlie poursuivi
depuis lors soyons achernés dans le
travail déterminé dans l'action
inscrivons nos politiques dans la durée
ne cédons rien au toririsme ni ici ni
ailleurs ne cédons rien à
l'obscurantisme au fanatisme défendons
les valeurs de la République madame la
Première ministre je vous sais
pleinement mobilisé et vous pourrez
compter sur notre soutien de républicain
exigeant madame le premierre ministre
pouvez nous dire quels sont vos
chantiers prioritaires pour assurer la
sécurité de nos
enseignantsci monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre vous avez la
parole merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le président Boris
Vallot c'est évidemment à dessin que les
islamiste s'en prennent à notre école
l'école c'est la promesse
républicaine l'école c'est là où l'on
combat les inégalités c'est là où le
goût de la liberté se transmet là où
notre jeunesse se forme cette école
c'est celle de nos enseignants et de
toute la communauté éducative et je veux
de nouveau leur homage leur dire tout
mon soutien est celui de mon
gouvernement ils sont les visages de la
transmission du savoir et de la
République alors nous protégeons nos
enseignants nous protégeons nos écoles
depuis 6 ans au côté des collectivité
nous avons investi pour mieux protéger
nos établissements scolaires ces
derniers jours j'ai réhaussé la posture
Vigi pirate et la sécurité aux abords
des établissements a été
renforcée transmettre la connaissance ne
peut se faire dans la peur monsieur le
Président Valot je sais les
responsabilités que votre groupe a su
prendre face au terrorisme je connais
son attachement aux valeurs
républicaines je connais sa volonté de
lutter sans cesse contre toutes les
haines dans un tel contexte nous avons
besoin d'unité nous avons besoin de
cohésion nationale nous avons besoin
d'un message clair face au terrorisme
qu'il frappe en France en Belgique ou en
Israël
monsieur le Président Vallot j'ai de
nombreuses fois parlé de l'arc
républicain et de celles et ceux qui
s'en exclus par leur propos ou par leurs
actes nous en avons vu ce matin un
terrible exemple je connais votre
sincérité et celle de votre groupe et
après les déclarations de ce matin
chacun sait sans équivoque qui défend la
République et ses valeurs qui ne les
partage pas je vous
remercie je vous remercie madame la
Première ministre
la parole est à Monsieur David guireud
pour le groupe la France insoumise merci
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre nous n'avons plus que quelques
heure pour éviter le pire en Palestine
ce samedi 14 octobre la rapporteur
spéciale de l'ONU dans les territoires
palestiniens occupés a déclaré je la
cite que les Palestiniens de Gaza
courent le risque d'un nettoyage
ethnique massif un nettoyage ethnique à
l'heure où nous parlons un million de
personnes de Palestiniens sont sous la
coupe d'un ordre d'évacuation que l'ONG
Médecin du Monde qualifie d'impensable
d'infaisable et d' e le président
israélien a averti le monde samedi
dernier en déclarant à propos des
Palestiniens je le cite que c'est toute
une nation qui est responsable il
annonce donc une punition collective
contre les Palestiniens pourtant
interdite par le droit international ce
même droit international qu'Israël a
déjà bafoué plus de 100 fois depuis 1947
nous n'avons plus que quelques heures
les milliers de bombes sur 2 millions de
civils la privation d'eau de nourriture
le déplacement forcé nous dirige vers
une catastrophe humanitaire mais aussi
une catastrophe diplomatique cette
catastrophe c'est l'anéantissement
définitif de la solution à deux états
car les Palestiniens déplacés de force
ne retrouveront pas probablement jamais
leur terre le Brésil devrait présenter
un texte au Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
pour appeler à un cesser le feu
humanitaire dans la bande de Gaza un
texte qui condamnerait également je le
cite les odieuses attaques terroristes
du Hamas confirmez-vous ces informations
la France va-t-elle soutenir ces
résolution car la France ne prend pas
ses responsabilités nous devons exiger
un cesser le feu pour compatriotes
franco-israéliens au tâes du Hamas nous
devons exiger un cesser le feu pour nos
compatriotes franco-palestiniens bloqués
à Gaza tellement absent de vos discours
d'ailleurs comment comptez-vous les
protéger nous devons tout faire pour que
le feu s'arrête la peine et la terreur
que nous avons éprouvé face au crime de
guerre du Hamas ne peut pas nous
conduire un soutien inconditionnel sur
ce que fait l'état israélien à Gaza la
France est trop silencieuse sur ce grave
risque de nettoyage ethnique la vie d'un
Palestinien ne vaut pas moins que la vie
d'un israéli
temp nous est compé faites vite madame
la Première
ministre je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame chou
zacaropouou secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats
internationaux merci Madame la Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
messieur les députés David
gu je vous prie d'abord de bien vouloir
excuser la ministre de l'Europe des
Affaires étrangères actuellement en
Moldavie
je viens maintenant à votre
question je vous rappelle qu'Israël a
été frappé par une offensive terroriste
sans précédent dans son
histoire je vous rappelle qu'elle est
Amama organisation terroriste est entré
en Israël pour tuer des Juifs des hommes
des femmes des enfants des bébés les AM
organisation terroriste et acoly
d'autres organisation terroriste a
perpétré un massacre un massacre et tout
le monde ici a vu les images ignobles
qui nous parviennent
d'Israël je vous rappelle aussi queelle
Amama organisation terroriste a pris en
notage des personnes âgées des enfants
des nourrissons je vous rappelle enfant
que parmi les victimes de cette barbarie
il y a de nombreux Français 21 français
qui ont perdu la vie plusieurs français
dont nous sommes sans nouvell et qui
sont probablement retenus en otage à
Gaza dans ce contexte dramatique la
position de la France est très claire
elle a été rappelée à des nombreuses
reprises à tous les niveaux la ministre
l'a rappelé aussi ces trois derniers
jours à ses interlocuteurs dans la
région face à l'horreur Israël a le
droit de se défendre et Israël doit le
faire en préservant les
CIV et dans le cadre des droit
international et des droits humanitaires
qui doivent être pleinement
respecté je vous remercie madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame
Véronique louvag pour le groupe
républicain merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué au compte public dans
quelques instant nous débuterons
l'examen en séance du PLF 2024 ce texte
budgétaire est une nelle occasion manqué
qui accroit le décrochage français et
fait en 2024 de la France l'un des pires
élèves de l'Europe nous avons le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire 44,1 % du PIB le
plus élevé d'Europe après le Danemark
notre taux de dépenses publique 55,9 %
est supérieur de 8 points à celui de la
moyenne de la zone euro en 2024 seul
trois pays auront un déficit plus élevé
que le nôtre ce déficit restera 4,4
points du PIB contre 2,4 points pour la
moyenne de la zone euro 3 % pour
l'Espagne 1,7 % pour l'Allemagne ou 0,8
% pour la Grèce nous sommes le 3è pays
le plus endetté d'Europe et je rappelle
qu'au moment de l'élection deemmanuel
Macron en 2017 7 pays 7 pays plus é
frendez excusez-moi 2 secondes madame
lovagie je vous demande de quitter
l'émisyle dans le silence s'il vous
plaît pour ne pas interrompre l'orateur
merci beaucoup madame louvag je vous
remercie madame la Présidente je disais
donc je rappelais qu'au moment de
l'élection de Emmanuel Macron en 2017 7
pays avaiit une dette plus élevée que la
France désormais il n'en reste plus que
deux nos finances sont aujourd'hui plus
dégradé que jamais or votre gouvernement
renonce à la fois à la baisse des impôts
pour les ménages et les entreprises en
revenant par exemple sur la suppression
de la CVAE dès 2024 pour pourtant
vootter l'an dernier également à la
diminution des dépenses publiques la
première ministre a annoncé en juin
dernier une diminution de 5 % des
crédits budgétaires hors masse salariale
cette promesse là encore ne sera pas
tenue mes questions sont simples
monsieur le ministre voulez-vous entrer
monsieur le ministre dans l'histoire
dans l'histoire de France en devenant le
premier ministre du Budget qui traduit
depuis 10 ans une diminution conséquente
des dépenses publiques une diminution
conséquente du déficit et une diminution
conséquente de l'endettement alors que
le Président de la République avait
promis la fin de l'abondance pourquoi
pourquoi avoir repoussé encore plus tard
le rétablissement de nos comptes je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas kazenav
ministre chargé des comptes
publics merci Madame la la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
madame la députée Véronique lovagie vous
savez nous défendons un projet de budget
qui vise à ramener notre déficit public
à 4,4 % en 2024 et repasser sous les 3 %
en 2027 nous pouvons le faire puisque
avant même les crises que nous avons
traversé nous avions ramené en 2017 2018
2019 notre déficit et pourquoi est-ce
que nous avons un déficit de 5 % parce
que nous avons protéger les Français
protéger les salariés protéger les
entreprises protéger les commerçants
protéger les associations protéger les
collectivité territoriale et vous
pourriez me poser la question est-ce que
nous avons bien fait moi je regarde
est-ce que notre pays continue à créer
des emplois oui est-ce que nous avons
une croissance plus élevée que nos
partenaires européens oui l'Allemagne
rentre en récession pas nous donc nous
avons bien fait de protéger est-ce que
pour autant il faut s'engager dans la
réduction des déficits publics oui et
pour ça en faisant des économies madame
louvagi nous faisons 16 milliards
d'euros d'économie en 2024 je rappelle
je rappelle en supprimant
progressivement le bouclier les
dispositifs exceptionnels et dans le
même temps vous nous demandez de
remettre une riston de carburant qui
nous coûterait 10 milliards d'euros donc
atten
inadctoir nous devons continuer à faire
des réformes des réformes structurelles
et nous sommes à l'écoute de vos
proposition pour faire d'autres
propositions d'économie mais aideznous
aussi à voter les réformes structurelles
qui nous permettent de faire des
économies comme la réforme des retraite
par exemple merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ministre la parole est à Madame NAD pour
le groupe
Renaissance
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Éducation nationale paraît
qu'on s'habitue à la pire barbarie
barbarie et pas plus aujourd'hui paraît
qu'on s'habitue aux horreurs qu'on vit
là mais l'innocent Contu je ne m'y
habitue pas quand gvincer écrivait ses
mots pour Samuel paatti nous étions loin
d'imaginer qu'il ne serait en fait que
le premier malgré le plus jamais ça
l'adre islamiste a encore frappé P à
haras en dayant à nouveau la communauté
nationale tant chacun de nous a pu
revoir dans les visage de Samuel Patier
et de Dominique Bernard les visages de
nos professeurs c'est cet espoir de
l'unité que le terrorisme islamiste
souhaite atteindre en faisant régner la
peur la terreur la fatalité mais il se
trompe lourdement la peur n'est pas dans
la gramère de la nation le renoncement
non plus
c'est cet espoir et cette unité que nos
enseignants transmettront encore et
toujours à nos enfants et nous
représentant de la nation souhaitons
leur exprimer ici et maintenant notre
profonde
reconnaissance hier nous avons tous pu
constater le dévouement et l'engagement
du corps professoral nous les avons vu
au collège du bois d'ne à Conflant
saint-honorine je les ai vu au collège
Montaigne dans les larmes dignes des
professeurs hier à leur côté j'étais
l'élève l'élève de ceux qui portent en
eux la force nécessaire pour aider nos
enfants à traverser cette épreuve et
permettre à la vie de reprendre son
cours cette communauté éducative a
besoin de ressources celles qui vont
permettre de dépasser les souffrances
psychologiques à forciorie lorsqu'il
doiv faire face à des provocations
indignes monsieur le ministre comment
ces moments de recueillement ont-ils été
observés et quelles sont les ressources
mises à disposition des équipes
éducatives pour traverser cette épreuve
et montrer que la France aime ses
enfants et qu'en France personne ne doit
avoir peur je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la députée la parole est
à Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la ministre madame la députée Nadia e
vous êtes élu des ivelines et nous
étions ensemble hier à Conflant
saint-onorine avec la première ministre
vous savez peut-être plus que tout autre
parce que vous avez vécu l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti dans votre territoire
combien ce traumatisme est lourd pour
les enseignants et hier c'est une
nouvelle onde de choc qui est arrivée à
conflan sainthonorine et combien nous
devons être à leur côté sur la question
de l'accompagnement psychologique j'ai
répondu à Madame roche tout à l'heure et
vous savez aussi combien il est
important pour eux de sentir la nation
tout entière à leur côté c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons souhaité
qu'hier à 14h la Nation toute entière
retienne son souffle en hommage à
Dominique Bernard en hommage à Samuel
Patti en hommage à tous les enseignants
de France parce que ce moment est
important j'avais été extrêmement clair
et extrêmement ferme à la veille de ce
moment en indiquant qu'il y aurait une
tolérance zéro pour la moindre
contestation ou la moindre provocation à
l'occasion de ces
moments veux le dire dans l'écrasante
majorité des cas dans la quasi totalité
des cas ce moment de recueillement ce
moment d'hommage s'est déroulé dans la
plus profonde dignité et le plus grand
respect je veux saluer les enseignants
et les élèves mais je dois le dire
aussi je dois le dire aussi 179 élèves
ont fait un autre choix celui de
perturber ce recueillement et de
provoquer l'école et d'insulter la
mémoire de nos professeurs notre nation
et notre école ne peuvent en aucun cas
tolérer cela et donc conformément aux
engagements que j'avais pris devant les
Français ce sont 179 césines du
procureur de la République qui partent
ce jour pour engager des poursuites
contre ses élèves
179 procédures disciplinaire qui partent
également et pour les cas les plus
graves plusieurs dizaines d'entre eux
qui relèvent de l'apologie du terrorisme
je le dis j'ordonne ce jour l'exclusion
de ces élèves dans l'attente des
procédures disciplinaires qui se
tiendront à un moment
merci
laill
c'est merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à monsieur
Alexandre SABATOU pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
cette question s'adresse à Madame Colona
ministre de l'Europe et des Affaires
étrangères madame la ministre vendredi
dernier la présidente de la Commission
européenne Ursula van derleyen s'est
imposée dans le déplacement de la
présidente du Parlement européen en
Israël pourquoi personne ne le sait
puisque la diplomatie ne fait pas partie
de ses prérogatives qu'elle n'a reçu
aucun mandat de qui que ce soit pour s'y
rendre et encore moins pour engager la
parole des pays européens malgré cela
elle a eu un entretien avec le Premier
ministre israélien et fait des
déclarations au nom de l'Européenne qui
ne représente pourtant que sa
sensibilité personnelle provoquant la
colère légitime des nations européennes
car en nettant d'évoquer l'obligation
d'Israël de respecter le droit
international dans sa ripose contre le
Hamas à Gaza c'est toute la diplomatie
de la France et de l'Europe au proche-
Orient qui est fragilisé en effet vous
saviez mieux que personne que des otages
français sont aux mains du Hamas et que
de tels propos tenu au nom de l'Europe
et donc de la France menace leur
intégrité et disonsle net menace leur
vie encore une fois la Commission
européenne a outrep passer ses pouvoirs
et encore une fois nous en payons le
prix comme toujours en temps de crise la
commission européne jalouse des pouvoirs
des nations souveraines s'arroge de
nouvelles prérogatives comme elle l'a
fait hier sur la santé avec le covid
elle le fait aujourd'hui sur la
diplomatie avec le conflit
israelllo-palestinien car oui en
abandonnant vos compétences à la
Commission en abandonnant vos pouvoirs
vous abandonner la voix de la France
aujourd'hui autrefois immense nation de
la diplomatie phare des pays non alignés
dont la parole était écoutée mais
surtout respecté la France avec vous est
devenue un simple télégraphiste de la
Commission européenne c'est pourquoi je
vous demande madame Mame la ministre
vous qui témoignez de vos meilleurs
sentiments à l'égard de Madame vleren
jusqu'à l'invité en grande pompe au
campus européen de renaissance il y a 10
jours combien de temps allez-vous encore
laisser reculer la voix de la France au
profit des technocrates de
Bruxelles je vous remercie la parole est
à Madame crissoua zacaropouou secrétaire
d'État chargé du développement de la
Francophonie et des partenariats
internationaux merci Madame la président
mesessieur les parlementairesieur les
déput SABATOU s'agissant de la visite de
Madame Verlen en Israël elle s'exprimait
àant que président de la Commission
européenne la position de l'Union
européenne est très claire a été
rappellée deè le 10 octobre par les
ministrre des Affaires étrangères de
l'Union européenne puis le 15 octobre
par les Conseil européen c'est-à-dire
les chefs d'État ou des gouvernements
des États membres dans une déclaration
publique l'Union européenne ainsi
condamné avec la plus grande fermeté les
attaques terroristes du Hamas perpétré
en Israël et rappeler les droit d'Israël
à se défendre conformément au droit
international et humanitaire elle a
réaffirmé l'importance des assurer la
protection de tous de tous les civils à
tout moment conformément au droit
international humanitaire la commission
Appell les Hamas à libérer immédiatement
tous les otages en qu' condition
préalable il a aussi été rappelé toute
l'importance d'un pêcer une escalade
régionale et l'attachement européen à
une paix durable et penne reposant sur
une solution fondée sur la coexistence
de deux états c'est dans cet esprit que
Catherine colon ministre de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères s'est rendit à
la demande du Président de la République
en Israël le 15 octobre en Égypte et au
Liban le 16 octobre s'agissant plus
spécifiquement de l'aide européenne là
encore la position de l'Union européenne
est très claire en examement en cours
afin de veiller à ce que cette aide ne
bénéficie pas au Hamas mais directement
population palestinenne c'est dans ce
contexte que madame vuderl a annoncé la
mise en place d'un pont aérienne
humanitaire avec Gaza via l'Égypte les
chefs d'État ou des gouvernement
européens auront l'occasion de revenir
sur l'ensemble de
aprsunire conse merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur le
député madame la ministre vous ne
répondez pas à la question et même sur
vos rangs cela divise madame l'oiseau a
dénoncé cette prise de parole mais au
final il n'y a pas qu's que la major
vous êtes fracturé chez vous également
toutécroule c'est peut-être ça la
mélanchonisation de
renaissance merci beaucoup la parole est
à
démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des solidarités et
des familles madame la ministre nous
sommes très nombreux sur ces bancs à
considérer que c'est l'honneur de notre
République que d'accompagner ses aînés
dans la dignité et la
considération pourtant nos aînés vivent
dans l'angoisse de ne plus pouvoir
régler leurs frais d'établissement ou
craignent de devenir une charge pour
leurs enfants et leurs petits enfants
il se demande si cette dernière partie
de leur vie va se dérouler dans de
bonnes conditions or nos épades sont à
bout de souffle les maires s'inquiètent
et se mobilisent les équilibres
financiers ne sont plus assurés avec
l'envolet des coups de fonctionnement
les directions et leur personnel
souffrent au quotidien la résignation
l'emportant sur la
vocation nous nous devons d'apporter une
réponse à ces inquié étude une réponse
qui soit à la hauteur du défi auquel
notre pays est confronté d'ici 2050 le
nombre de personnes âgé de 75 à 84 ans
en France connaîtra une hausse de près
de 50 % rendant d'autant plus
indispensable une réponse ambitieuse à
la problématique du grand âge les
parlementaires Bretons se mobilisent
avec les maires pour les éepad mais je
sais que l'ensemble de mes collègues
quel que soit leur sensibilité politique
partage cette préoccupation envers ces
personnes âgées envers ses familles
envers ses soignants bien sûr cette
majorité n'est pas restée passive en
2020 nous avons créé not 5ème branche
dédiée à l'autonomie aujourd'hui vous
portez madame la ministre une réforme
ambitieuse du financement des éepades
demain il nous faudra traiter la
dépendance dans toute son ampleur et sa
complexité loin des rustines comme un
éam crédit d'impôt loin des procè
d'intention et des postures nous devons
des réponses à toutes ces familles ainsi
madame la ministre pouvez-vous nous nous
dire comment et avec quels moyens vous
comptez agir pour que nos aînés puissent
bien vieillir je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Madame Aurore
berger ministre des Solidarités et des
familles merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
monsieur le le député Michel Cosson
merci pour la question qui permet de
rappeler l'engagement des députés de la
majorité sur cette question nous nous
réunissions dès cette été avec des
maires des Côtes d'Armor et du
finisterère et vous-même et un certain
nombre de parlementaires qui sont
engager évidemment dans les territoires
parce que vous avez raison le choc
démographique auquel notre pays va faire
face est probablement l'une des plus
grandes transitions à laquelle
l'ensemble de notre société doit se
préparer ça n'est pas juste en vérité la
question des épades et de leur modèle
économique qui est posé c'est donc
l'adaptation de l'ensemble de notre
société comment garantir à nos personnes
âgées vieillissantes de pouvoir rester à
domicile puisque c'est d'abord leur
première volonté comment garantir leurs
droits tout au long de leur parcours de
vie comment faire en sorte que nos épes
P soit mieux médicalisé pour faire face
aux maladies neurodégénératives comment
avoir un parcours résidentiel entre le
domicile et les pad et comment garantir
leur inclusion pleine et entière à
l'ensemble de notre société c'est ça le
défi qui est posé par l'adaptation de
notre société au vieillissement et trop
souvent on voit ça comme un déclin ça
n'est en rien un déclin c'est d'abord
une formidable nouvelle que nous ayons
une espérance de vie en bonne santé qui
continue à progresser d'année après
année c'est la capacité que nous avons à
faire en sorte que nos aînés soient
inclus dans la société partagent leur
expérience soit des élus de la
République soit des milliers des
milliers de bénévoles associatifs qui
s'engagent soit des grands-parents qu'on
ait encore une fois cette expérience et
oui nous avons besoin pour cela de
financement c'est pour cela que nous
avons voté la création de la branche
autonomie et que nous le finançons c'est
pour cela que je souhaite aussi engager
une réforme ambitieuse des fonds de
concours de la CNSA parce que c'est bien
ici que nous aurons des véritables
modalités de financement sur le long
terme en lien avec les départements
parce que par que tout cela nous ne
pouvons pas le faire seul il y a ce que
l'État peut il y a ce que les
législateurs veulent et vous pourrez
faire dans la loi bien vieillir
notamment il y a aussi ce que les
collectivité local font et c'est
ensemble que nous adopterons notre
société je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Nathalie
Bassir pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
lot merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre des outremes monsieur le minist
ministre samedi dernier un amendement
signé par le rapporteur général du
budget a été déposé en misou en vue de
l'examen du PLF 2024 en séance publique
ce soir visant notamment à supprimer le
bénéfice de l'aide fiscale 1 en faveur
des biens destinés notamment à la
consommation des particuliers des
chauffeaux solaires par exemple deux sur
tous les meublés touristiques
individuels et collectifs 3 sur les
véhicules de tourisme notamment de
location soit un total de 160 millions
d'euros en moins pour l'activité et
l'emploi a-t-on mesuré l'ampleur de des
conséquences économiques et sociales sur
nos territoires ultramarin sachant
qu'aucune justification sérieuse n'a été
fournie ni la moindre analyse des
impacts sur l'emploi et sur la création
de valeur sans parler du problème de
fond et de méthode que posent de telles
annonces si brutales sans concertation
avec les acteurs du monde économique
notamment ultrarin comme c'est
regrettable seul lignes du rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances
publié le 6 octobre dernier sont
consacrés au meublés touristique et 14
lignes au véhicules de tourisme est-ce
ainsi que vous justifiez de telles
décisions en dépit de deux mesures
d'ouverture positive sur le photo
voltaïque et les friches cet amendement
conduit à la suppression du bénéfice de
l'aide fiscale à l'investissement sur
des secteurs d'activité important de nos
économies
ultramarines un dialogue constructif
aurait permis de calibrer et affiner les
réponses techniques permettant de
répondre à certains enjeux légitimes
soulevés par les pouvoirs publics sans
pour autant supprimer un pan entier de
l'aide fiscale en faveur d'activités
structurante pouvez-vous s'il vous plaît
communiquer sans délai à la
représentation nationale les analyses
d'impact des mesures que vous proposez
analyse indispensable pour éclairer
notre vote en l'absence de ces éléments
comme de concertation sérieuse préalable
allez-vous en responsabilité monsieur le
ministre reporter l'examen de cet
amendement je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe Vigier ministre en
charge des outr m merci madame la
Présidente madames Messieurs les Députés
madame la députée merci Madame la député
de me donner l'occasion de dire que le
budget des outremes c'est 7 % de plus en
2024 ça montre bien que le gouvernement
Neisse pas la garde mais au contraire va
financer beaucoup plus les remurs qui en
ont tant besoin c'est beaucoup plus
d'argent pour le logement vous avez pas
parlé c'est 50 millions d'euros de plus
pour ce qu'on appelle la ligne
budgétaire unique c'est beaucoup plus
d'argent pour les collectivités 22
millions d'euros de plus pour l'ensemble
des collectivités c'est 40 millions de
plus pour accompagner les collectivités
qui ont des difficultés financières
c'est 300 millions d'euros de plus pour
l'eau voyez donc madame la députée si je
parle également des écoles c'est 320
millions d'euros de plus mais là-dessus
vous passez tout sous silence je
comprends vous m'interrogez sur une huge
fiscale elles sont déjà toutes
maintenues jusqu'en 2028 simplement on
va faire une chose on va corriger celles
qui sont inefficaces je viens à dire par
exemple devant le ministre de
l'Agriculture que les véhicules
utilitaires continueront de bénéficier
de la défiscalisation pas les véhicules
pour les personnes individuelles c'est
vrai on on conservera tout ce qui
produit de la valeur pareil pour les
équipements touristiques que ce soit un
hôtel que ce soit des gites touristiques
ils continueront de bénéficier de des
fiscalisations et nous trouverons
ensemble un chemin pour ceux qui ont
comme vous le savez euh des petits
logements qu'il louent quelquefois et là
on trouve ouvra un calibrage ensemble
dans le cadre de la discussion
budgétaire vous dire que l'efficacité on
l'a voulu aussi il aurait fallu dire
pour la transition énergétique par
exemple toutes les rénovations
thermiques seront soumis à des
fiscalisations ce qui n'existait pas
auparavant je tiens à le souligner pour
les autoconsommation avec les
équipements photovoltaïques ça
n'existait pas nous allons le faire en
2024 donc voyez que le pouvoir d'achat a
guidé nos mesures et je dis devant le
ministre du Budget qui est là qu'on
trouvera ensemble les solutions pour
faire en sorte de trouver pour C ce qui
notamment les loueurs de voitures à
titre individuel seraient pénalisé une
voie de sortie donc ce budget est un
budget à l'offensive qui va permettre
d'aider les territoires ultraarins ils
en ont besoin besoin on le feront
ensemble merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Franck
alizio pour le rassemblement
national
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Bruno Lemer
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique de la France
jeudi prochain aura lieu la 21e édition
de la Fête des entreprises et de
l'opération j'aime ma boîte je saisis
cette occasion pour que nous puissions
saluer ici dans cet hémicycle tous nos
entrepreneurs nos salariés toute cette
France qui travaille dur qui crée de la
richesse et qui Innov merci à
eux cette France qui bosse a d'autant
plus de mérite qu'elle essaie de réussir
malgré votre politique une politique qui
fait de la France la championne des
impôts et des taxes de la bureaucratie
mais aussi des déficits de la dette
publique qui sont les impôts de demain
George ppidou exhorté ses ministres à je
cite arrêtez d'emmerder les Français
nous savons depuis le covid qu'Emmanuel
Macron vous encourage à faire l'inverse
en spectateur de votre dépôt de bilan
vous en appelez sur les plateaux de télé
à simplifier tout ce qui pourra l'atre
pour les entrepreneurs sans jamais
joindre la parole aux
en résumé Bruno oublie tout simplement
que le maire est ministre de l'Économie
depuis maintenant près d'un long sepéna
même des nid de réalité lorsque vous
affirmez que les impôts ont baissé alors
qu'ils ont bel et bien augmenté tant en
valeur relative qu'absolue ma question
est simple monsieur le ministre à quand
votre reconnexion avec le réel à quand
la fin de ce double discours à quand la
fin de cette politique mortifère qui qui
qui pour faire pour faire place à un
vrai projet économique qui libère les
Français permet au travail d'enfin payer
et au patriotisme économique de
s'exprimer merci beaucoup la parole est
est à Madame Olivia Grégoire ministre
chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises du commerce de l'artisanat
et du
[Applaudissements]
tourisme merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le le député
alizio 11
milliards de baisse d'impôt sur les
sociétés depuis 2017 11
milliards une baisse d'impôt sur les
sociétés de 33 % à 25
% pendant que Daquin rigolait et rigole
encore on vous entend qui a baissé les
impôts des entreprises depuis 6 ans qui
a baissé l'impôt sur les sociétés qui a
baissé avec courage dans des moments
compliqués les impôts de production qui
enclenche une baisse de 9 milliards sur
la CVAE alors même que c'était au cœur
et je crois que c'est le sens de votre
question du problème de compétitivité
français savez-vous monsieur le député
quel est le différenciel d'impôt de
production entre la France et
l'Allemagne parce qu'il est facile de
pérorer sur une paire de chaussures par
exemple de 60 € avez-vous une idée du
différentiel qu'il y avait en matière
d'impôt de production c'était 2 € en
France Monsieur monsieur soyons précis
c'est 30 centimes en Allemagne on
cherche où est la compétitivité on
cherche où sont les marges pour redonner
du pouvoir d'achat augmenter les
salaires comme ça a été fait par
l'ensemble des entreprises françaises
depuis un an ils étaient là les
gisements de croissance ils sont là les
marges de manœuvre d'entreprise la
baisse d'impôts sur les sociétés la
baisse des impôts de production ce sont
des choses qui ont été faite la preuve
en est aujourd'hui quelle est la réalité
monsieur il y a 7 ans lorsqu'on est
arrivé on nous disait aidez-nous aider
nos enfants à trouver du boulot
qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit dans vos
circonscriptions aujourd'hui aidez-nous
à trouver des salariés les carnets de
commande sont pleins ça vous fait
sûrement sourire mais nos artisans nos
PME sont compétitives quel est le pays
d'Europe cette année qui aura une
croissance positive là où l'Allemagne
est en récession qui est-ce et grâce à
qui c'est nous notre majorité pendant
que ça papote et que ça discute il y en
a qui bosent depuis 6 ans pour soutenir
les PME de fr merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsie
alio dans les faits dans les faits votre
bilan c'est plus d'impôt et plus de
dettes et en cela Macron rime de plus en
plus avec
Mélenchon je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur mathas tel pour la France
insoumise
merci madame la Première ministre vous
avez tenu hier une conférence sociale
avec les représentants des salariés et
du patronat pour être à la hauteur de
l'attente des Français elle aurait dû
porter sur le financement des retraites
et l'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans
comme le veut la majorité de nos
concitoyens et de cette Assemblée
nationale en dépit de toutes vos
manœuvres antidémocratiques
elle aurait dû acter la hausse du SMIC
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation la fin des cadeaux aux
actionnaires et des exonérations de
Cotis sociale sans
contrepartie à la place vous n'avez
inventé qu'un nouveau comité Théodule
sur les
rémunérations encore une fois vous
récidivez dans votre préférence
actionnariale là où les Français
attendent la préférence salariale que
nous défendons dans le même temps vous
n'avez toujours pas renoncé à
ponctionner 1 milliard d'euros dans les
caisses des retraites complémentaires
des salariés du privé malgré
l'opposition unanime du patronat et des
syndicats de salariés
vous vous apprêtez ainsi à raquetter 13
millions de retraités alors même que le
Conseil d'orientation des retraites dit
que les pensions complémentaires vont
baisser quand il s'agit d'exiger un peu
du patronat vous renvoyer tout à plus
tard quand il s'agit de voler 2 ans de
vie ou 1 milliard d'euros au
travailleurs vous frappez vite et fort
vous êtes plus doué pour faire les
poches des Français que pour les remplir
pourtant il suffirait par exemple de
revenir sur les exonérations de
cotisation sociale ou à minima de les
conditionner pour dégager des recettes
nouvelles pour la sécurité sociale quand
allez-vous enfin conditionner ces 206
milliards d'euros annuels d'aide
publique aux entreprises allez-vous
enfin renoncer à l'idée de ponctionner
les caisses de retraite complémentaires
du privé jusqu'à quand allez-vous
préférer la maltraitance sociale à la
justice et au
progrès merci la parole est à madame
Carole Grandjean ministre chargée de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Tavel vous
interrogez le gouvernement au fond sur
différents sujet celui de la conférence
sociale et du dialogue social que nous
engageons avec les partenaires sociaux
depuis de long Moiss maintenant et qui a
fait l'objet hier d'une conférence
sociale mais également sur l'argir Carco
qui a euh sur l'accord des partenaires
sociaux euh vise à conclure un sur la
retraite complémentaire à gerer Carco et
sur le avec le gouvernement des débats
sur le sujet sur l'argir Carco je
voudrais dire que la position du
gouvernement n'a pas varié que les
partenaires sociaux se sont accordé sur
un ensemble des dépenses nouvelles qu'il
s'agisse de l'indexation des pensions ou
de la suppression du bonus malus ces
dépenses nouvelles elles sont
importantes avec des effets pour
l'avenir qui sont pour partie financé
par le rendement de la réforme des
retraites que nous avons porté la
réforme des retraites génère pour
l'argir Carco 1,2 milliards d'excédents
à l'horizon 2026 et jusqu'à 3 milliards
à l'horizon 2030 c'est le seul effet
mécanique de la réforme des moindres
dépenses du régime compte tenu du
décalage de l'âge de départ de la
retraite nous avons toujours été
transparents depuis le début des
concertations fin 2022 nous avons
défendu un équilibre du système des
retraites tout régime à horizon 2030
tout régime c'est c'est-à-dire en
intégrant les régimes de base et les
régimes complémentaires nous avons fait
le choix de la confiance dans le
dialogue social et c'est le cas de cette
conférence sociale qui à l'issue d'une
journée riche en diagnostic et en prise
de position mais aussi en débat a permis
à la première ministre de faire des
annonces des annonces nombreuses et qui
sont le résultat des discussions
engagées avec les partenaires sociaux je
pense au Conseil des rémunération je
pense au dialogue de branche qui va être
réactivé je pense au calcul des
exonérations non plus sur la base du
SMIC mais sur celle des minimas de
branche ou encore au nouvel indexe de
l'égalité professionnelle voilà autant
de pistes qui ont été débattues hier et
que nous porterons dans le cadre du
dialogue social merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à monsieur le
rapporteur général cas9 pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse au ministre des
comptes
publque nous examinons à partir
d'aujourd'hui le budget 2024 en tant que
rorteur général je suis très fier de
soutenir ce texte qui d'abord renforce
les ministères régaliens un moment où la
menace n'a jamais été aussi forte comme
le rappelle les terribles événements de
la semaine dernière ce sont 3,3
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
nos armées 1 milliard pour l'intérieur
500 millions pour le ministère de la
justice c'est aussi un PLF qui renforce
notre transition écologique avec 7
milliards d'euros supplémentaires ce
sont plus de possibilités pour les
Français de changer leur voiture ou
d'isoler leur tion plus d'argent pour
les collectivités territoriales pour
rénover leurs écoles et changer leurs
éclairages public c'est aussi un PLF qui
protège le pouvoir d'achat des Français
nous revalorisons les retraites les
minimas sociaux nous prolongeons le
bouclier nous indexons l'impôt sur le le
revenu enfin c'est un budget qui assure
le désendettement de notre pays avec un
objectif de 4,4 % de déficit l'année
prochaine le débat de fond s'est posé en
commission il a été de grande intensité
même si je regrette l'alliance des
contraires qui ont rejeté ce budget d'un
côté ceux qui proposent l'austérité et
des dizaines de taxes et d'impôts
supplémentaires de l'autre ce qui parl
de gabgi mais propose des amendements
qui pousse des dizaines de milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires et qui renforce
de fait notre conviction que notre
projet est ambitieux équilibré
responsable ma question ma question
monsieur le le ministre et nous
traversons une nouvelle crise au
Moyen-Orient avec un impact sur la
croissance mondiale avec un impact
probablement sur le prix du pétrole quel
pourrait être l'impact pour notre budget
de cette crise merci merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur général la parole
est à Monsieur Thomas knav ministre en
charge des comptes
publics merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les députés
monsieur le le rapporteur général vous
vous m'interrogez sur les conséquences
du du conflit au Proche Orient sur notre
budget d'abord vous dire que nous sommes
dans une situation où les incertitudes
économiques sont importante celle-ci il
est aujourd'hui trop tôt pour dire si
elle aura une conséquence sur nos
prévisions de croissance sur notre
inflation néanmoins nous avons au-delà
de ce conflit le ralentissement chinois
la politique monétaire de taux d'intérêt
élevés qui sont autant d'incertitude sur
finalement le climat économique autour
autour de nous c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons déjà revu notre
prévision de croissance de 1,6 % à
1,4 % nous avons par par ailleurs
maintenu notre hypothèse d'inflation à
2,5 %. dans cette période d'incertitude
j'ai une conviction il faut poursuivre
le redressement de nos finances
publiques pourquoi parce que ce qui nous
a permis d'affronter les crises
successivbles c'est nous avions retrouvé
des marges de manœuvre ramener le
déficit à 2,3 % donc si j'avais 1
message dans le climat d'incertitude
dans lequel aujourd'hui nous avançons
nous devons pas dévier de la politique
de redressement de nos finances
publiques la réduction de notre déficit
public nous avons besoin d'économie 16
milliards en 2024 mais nous en avons
besoin dans les années suivantes nous
devons continuer les réformes
structurelles les marges aujourd'hui qui
nous permettent de mettre en œuvre les
priorités rappelé par le rapporteur
général c'est aussi la réforme de
l'assurant chômage c'est aussi la
réforme des retraites nous avons encore
besoin de réformes structurelles pour
redresser nos finances publiques et
ramener notre déficit public à moins de
3 % d'ici 2027 je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Madame Sabrina
cebaé pour le groupe
écologiste merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères depuis plusieurs
quinquena la politique étrangère de
notre pays tourne le dos à nos valeurs
et nos positions historiques
au Moyen-Orient notre influence et notre
voix celle d'un pays non aligné et
pouvant dialoguer avec tous
appartiennent désormais au 20e siècle
votre gouvernement aurait dû avoir un
discours simple condamnation du Hamas et
rejet des représailles aveugles du
gouvernement israélien comme la Norvège
et l'Espagne ou encore le secrétaire
général de l'ONU l'attaque terroriste du
Hamas assassinant des civils israéliens
a suscité à juste titre un émoin et une
condamnation partout dans le monde mais
àheure où nous parlons près de 800
enfants palestiniens ont été tués lors
de frappe israélienne et face à cet
effroyable carnage qu'avez-vous dit rien
ou si peu qu'avez-vous dit au président
qu'avez-vous dit en réponse au président
israélien qui a déclaré je cite qu'il
n'y a aucun innocent à Gazin
qu'avez-vous dit en réponse au ministre
de la Défense israélien qui disait
combattre des animaux rien ou si peu la
position de la France signataire de la
Convention de Genève au même titre
qu'Israël est de considérer que toute
frappe contre des infrastructures et des
personnes civiles constituent un crime
de guerre pour être cohérent avec nos
valeurs humanistes et le droit
international ne devrions-nous pas
appliquer ce principe universel aussi à
Gaza pour le gouvernement d'extrême
droite israélien la vie d'un Palestinien
vaut moins que celle d'un Israélien ceux
qui soutiennent de manière
inconditionnelle netanahou dans cet
hémicycle se font partisan de cette
théorie et tourne ainsi le dos à la
société civile israélienne qui conteste
massivement ce gouver
j'ai entendu votre non réponse à mon
collègue David guirou mais le respect du
droit international s'applique à tous et
il implique de ne pas bombarder de
manière continue des populations et
infrastructures civiles de ne pas couper
l'accès à l'eau à l'électricité et au
vivre car tout cela est pass possible de
crime de guerre madame la ministre
faites votre mot faites votre les mots
du président Chirak tant que les
Palestiniens n'ont pas droit à la
dignité comme tous les autres peuples je
peux terminer la questionouy alors je
terminerai pas la citation mais quand
allez-vous demander
deéger les populations civiles
palestinen je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Madame
chrou pour secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internation merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames messies les députés
madame la députée
Sabrina face à la situation dramatique
au
prient la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires
étrangères rendu à la demande du
Président de la
République AV à TelAviv à Jérusalem au C
beyouth d'une part pour afficher notre
soutien à Israël ma dans sa chair par le
terrorisme d'autre part pour appeler
l'assemble des acteurs de la région à la
responsabilité durant les exactions et
les massacres commis par les Hamas 21
français ont été
tués face à l'horreur
l'Israël comme il a é dit à le droit de
se défendre Israël doit le faire dans le
respect du droit international et en
prenant en compte la protection des
populations civiles contrairiement à ce
que vous dites la France se tient
également au côté des population
palestiniennees et ne sont pas
responsables de la situation et il faut
se garder de confondre les Hamas avec
l'assemble de la population
palestinienne ceux qui les font
commettent une faute et nous sommes très
clairs sur ce point depuis le premiier
jours de plus la France agit pour leur
venir en aide caerine Colona a hier
annoncer une aide de 10 millions d'euros
profite des agences des Nations Unies et
internationales et des ONG humanitaires
au bénéfice direct des populations de
Gaza au-delà des efforts sont en cours
pour ouvrir un couloir humanitaire afin
que l'aide des Nations Unies puisse être
acheminé parfa et parvienne au
population après contrôle cette aide est
prête
doit maintenant pouvoir passer c'est une
urgence enfin je répète l'appel lancé
par la ministre tous les civil qui
souhaitent partir de Gaza doivent
pouvoir le faire lesas ne peut pas
prendreage toute une
population merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur le
pour le groupe
gdradame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
avec tout le respect que je vous dois
madame la Première ministre vous
êtes-vous déjà douché avec de l'eau
somatre silené d'Or l'ossomatre est une
haau salée dégange dégageant une odeur
nauséeabonde c'est le quotidien des
habitants de l'archipel des Tamou et
particulièrement des élèves de
l'internat du collège de Rangiroa faute
d'osmoseur Mayotte et la Guadeloupe font
l'actualité ces derniers jours mais il
ne sont que la partie émergée d'une
crise majeure silencieuse qui touche
l'ensemble des outes
l'accès à l'eau potable fait partie des
droits humains reconnus à l'échelle
internationale et découlant du Pacte
international relatif aux droits
économiques socio et culturels texte
ratifié par la France en 1980 43 ans
plus tard pénurie et stress hydrique
continuent d'être le quotidien des
habitants de Saint-Laurent du Maroni de
Saint-Leu ou encore de pou en canaki
compétences partagées entre les communes
les intercommunalités ou encore les
offices de l'eau la solution ne réside
pas dans l'envoi massif de bouteill
d'eau il est vital de proposer un fond
dans lequel nos collectivités
territoriales puissent puiser des
financements supplémentaires pour
rénover les conduits d'eau pour investir
dans des systèmes de filtrage type
osmoseur ou type centrale énergie
thermique des
mers financement supplémentairire
nécessaire particulièrement en Polynésie
car les communes ne peuvent pas lever
l'impôt et sont dépendants des fonds de
l'État et du pays maori il est inélégant
de ma part d'évoquer ce sujet sans
remercier les ministres d'armanin et
Vigier qui font la tournée de nos pays
respectifs en ce moment pour apporter
des solutions mais les solutions
apportées au congoutte ne sont pas
suffisants madame la Première ministre
combien de fonds supplémentaires à ce à
ce qui existe déjà actuellement qui sont
insuffisants pouvez-vous débloquer pour
soutenir les investissements de nos
communes pour une véritable
planification de l'accès à l'eau pour
tous
partout merci beaucoup chers collègu la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe Vigier
ministre des outres mers merci madame la
présidente madame messieurs les députés
monsieur le député le gayic d'abord
poser une question absolument centrale
c'est celle de l'eau et vous avez raison
de le dire on parle beaucoup de Mayotte
on parle beaucoup de la Guadeloupe mais
l'ensemble des territoires ultramarins
et puis largement l'Hexagone est est
concerné tant le réchauffement
climatique est là et tant justement la
fourniture d'eau et en particulier notre
capacité de main par exemple à mieux
dessaliser l'eau est absolument
indispensable d'abord vous dire que
l'État depuis 2016 a fait des efforts
considérables je tiens à dire que ça
soit en guyan en Guadeloupe à la Réunion
à Saint-Martin efforts considérables qui
sont traduit par un moyen des moment
pardon des moyensinvestissement de
l'ordre de 50 million d'euros
supplémentaires chaque année également
un accès à l'emprun de 60 millions
d'euros tous les ministères sont
concernés et on a même mis des moyens
techniques des bras en clair pour
accompagner les collectivités parce que
vous savez très bien que l'affaire de
l'eau c'est l'affaire aussi des
collectivités mais l'État est présent et
on a mobilisé n interrogé la première
ministre avec par exemple l'Office
français de la biodiversité avec
l'Agence française de développement avec
la Caisse des dépôt et consignation on n
franchi un un pas supplémentaire l'année
dernière avec l'annonce du président de
la République de mettre 35 millions
d'euros en plus mesures du sium auquel
vous faites référence le fameux comité
interministériel au outre ma je suis en
capacité de vous dire qu'à l'heure où
nous parlons en Guadeloupe le président
du département de la Guadeloupe signe
avec le préfet un contrat de 320 million
d'euros j'ai répondu la semaine dernière
aux questions sur Mayotte où on a une
situation absolument dégradée
désastreuse sur lesquel on a pris des
décision très forte de prendre en charge
vous savez les factures de faire en
sorte que on a chemine des bouteilles
d'eau en attendant d'avoir des
équipements structurant comme ceux
auquels vous faites référence les fameux
osmoseurs ce que nous faisons en
godeloupe ce que nous faisons à Mayotte
nous le ferons également chez vous parce
que nous laisserons pas tomber les
Français qu'il soient ultramarin ou
qu'il soit naturellement des hexagonaux
comptez sur mon engagement total et
sueli de tous les gouvernement de tous
les ministères concernés pour trouver
avec vous les bonnes solution merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur dorf
pour le groupe
Renaissance merci madame la Présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre madame la Première
ministre la situation en
Nouvelle-Calédonie est catastrophique
l'incertitude institutionnelle a mené
une perte de 10 % de notre population
depuis 5 ans nous perdons deux points de
PIB par an et par habitant depuis cette
même période nos trois usines de nickel
les poumons économiques de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie sont en quasi
faillite et les actionnaires comme
heramet ou Glencore ont déjà annoncé
qu'ils arrêtaient de financer les
différents outils de production alors
que le panier alimentaire en
Nouvelle-Calédonie reste à 80 % plus
élevé qu'en France
métropolitaine
madame la Première ministre vous nous
avez déjà beaucoup aidé vous avez versé
une subvention de 33 millions d'euros il
y a quelques semaines pour équilibrer
les comptes sociaux de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais dans le même
temps vos services mettent une pression
énorme sur le gouvernement de la
nouvelle Calédonie pour que nous
augmentions les impôts locaux nous
sommes en train de vivre une semaine
fiscale noire en Nouvelle-Calédonie
puisque c'est 200 millions d'euros
d'impôts qui sont demandai en plus aux
calédoniens ce qui équivaut à doubler
l'impôt sur revenu au niveau local alors
que nous savons madame la Première
ministre que augmenter les impôts sur
une économie malade n'est pas utile et
c'est en totale contradiction avec la
politique économique qui est menée en
France
métropolitaine la la solution madame la
Première ministre on la connaît tous
c'est enfin d'offrir à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie un nouveau statut en
réformant la constitution de manière à
pouvoir offrir à la Nouvelle-Calédonie
des perspectives durables madame la
Première ministre ma question est donc
simple est-ce que vous vous engagez à
réformer la Constitution le plus
rapidement possible pour enfin aboutir à
un nouveau statut de la
NouvelleCalédonie ancré dans la France
de manière définitive je vous remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à madame la Première
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Nicolas
metzdorf comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le député le processus
politique prévu par les accords de numea
est allé à son terme et les Calédoniens
par trois fois ont choisi de demeurer
français notre devoir collectif c'est
désormais de dessiner l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie au plan économique
vous l'avez dit à quel point l'enjeu du
nickel est fondamental mais aussi au
plan institutionnel pour cela il y avait
un préalable créer les conditions d'un
dialogue serein et
constructif avec les indépendantistes et
les non indépendantistes c'est ce que
nous nous nous sommes employés à faire
ces derniers mois avec le président de
la République et le gouvernement lors de
sa visite en Nouvelle-Calédonie en
juillet dernier le président de la
République a invité les acteurs
politiques à travailler à la recherche
de consensus sur tous les sujets en
empruntant deux chemins celui du pardon
et celui de l'avenir c'est ce sens de la
semaine de discussion qui s'est tenue
début septembre à Paris à mon invitation
j'ai réuni l'ensemble des acteurs à
Matignon et le ministre de l'Intérieur
et des outr-emèes Gérald d'Anin a tenu
de nombreux échanges avec les
délégations à l'issue de ces travaux le
président de la République a réuni
toutes les parties pour dresser des
perspectives avec pour cap la conclusion
d'un accord d'ici la fin de l'année un
projet d'accord a été transmis la
semaine dernière par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des outres Mair Gérald
armanin et je sais que les discussions
sont en cours sur les thèmes de la
citoyenneté calédonienne de
l'autodétermination du statut et des
institutions et je vous confirme le
moment venu le gouvernement présentera
en conséquence un projet de révision
constitutionnelle celui-ci devra
notamment permettre le dégel du corps
électoral qui est une exigence
démocratique les Calédoniens seront
amenés à approuver le projet d'accord
comme ils l'ont fait pour les accords de
N en
1998 et une fois l'accord en vigueur les
élections provinciales pourront se tenir
je connais monsieur le député Nicolas
metsdorf votre mobilisation pour porter
la voix et les aspirations des
Calédoniens notre objectif c'est de
donner des perspectives à tous les
Calédoniens notamment les plus jeunes
notre objectif c'est de leur permettre
de se projeter et de construire le leur
avenir en Nouvelle-Calédonie et dans la
République je vous remercie merci merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre la
parole est à monsieur Adrien catnins
pour le groupe LFI merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Roland lescur ministre délégué chargé de
l'Industrie monsieur le ministre
anciennement Usinor mg vdune est la
seule entreprise implantée en France
produisant des roues et des essieux
ferroviaires ou des galets utilisés pour
la maintenance des écluses reprise en
2014 par le groupe chinois masty
l'entreprise a vu ses effectifs passer
de à 340 salariés répartis entre l'usine
de tri Saint-Léger près de Valencienne
et celle de lefreincoup près de
dunkererc depuis la reprise les pertes
s'enchaînent 16 millions d'euros rien
qu'en 2022 en cause le manque
d'investissement du repreneur
contrairement à ces engagements
l'abandon programmé de l'outil
industriel entraînant retard et
pénalités des salariés m'ont même
indiqué que dès la reprise le repreneur
avait filmé les process de production et
copié les brevets afin de les transférer
vers les sites de production chinois sa
mauvaise besogne réalisée l'actionnaire
majoritaire a annoncé se retirer du
capital de l'entreprise nous sommes ici
confrontés à une prédation industrielle
bien connue face à laquelle les pouvoirs
publics restent trop souvent immobiles
les salariés eux par la voix de la CGT
porent un projet chiffré pour l'avenir
de MG valdune ce projet s'appuie sur une
logique de filière réunissant l'ensemble
des acteurs du ferroviaire de la SNCF à
Alstom en passant par les collectivité
ce jeudi à Bery une table ronde est
organisée pour l'avenir de l'entreprise
elle rassemblera acteurs privés et
collectivités monsieur le ministre vous
y représenterez l'état on ne peut pas
parler de planification écologique et
pas d'avantage de souveraineté
industriel et laisser couler valdune
monsieur le ministre quels engagements
comptez-vous prendre afin d'accompagner
efficacement le projet de la CGT pour
valdune et ces 340 salariés je vous
remercie merci beaucoup la parole est à
Monsieur Roland lescur ministre en
charge de
l'Industrie merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les député monsieur
le député catnins d'abord la
souveraineté industrielle elle ne se
décrète pas ce n'est pas un slogan elle
n'est pas non plus dans le petit manuel
du Trotski s'illustré la politique
industrielle de la France que nous
menons depuis 6 ans elle a réussi à
créer de l'emploi à créer des
entreprises à créer des usines vous avez
voté systématiquement contre depuis 6
ans je tiens à le rappeler la stratégie
industrielle monsieur le député c'est
aussi une stratégie qui dossier après
dossier travaille inlassablement avec
l'ensemble des acteurs les organisations
syndicales que je rencontre depuis le
début sur ce dossier y compris au niveau
national les actionnaires que vous
détestezant les directions d'entreprise
les élus locaux régionaux et nationaux
et depuis que l'actionnaire a annoncé de
se à se désengager c'était en mai
dernier plus de 10 ans après
l'investissement initial nous avons
rencontré les des salariés sur le
terrain une semaine un mois après pardon
après les avoir reçus à Bercy nous avons
négocié avec l'actionnaire des primes
des salaires des commandes qui nous ont
permis de gagner du temps qui font
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le temps de
trouver des repreneurs ces repreneurs je
m'y engage ils doivent être crédibles
être capable eux-mêmes de s'engager dans
l'avenir des sites ensemble ou
séparément comme tous les salariés
impliqués dans ce dossier je je
préférerais un repreneur crédibl sur les
desites pour l'instant je n'en ai pas en
revanche nous avons des marques
d'intérêt réel pour trisinléger et pour
les frein Cook et nous les travaillons
et en parallèle suite à la réunion que
j'ai eu avec Sophie Binet suite à des
discussions que j'ai eu avec des élus
représentés sur ce ban Fabier Roussel
que je vois ici Paul Christophe et
tendrô nous travaillons effectivement
avec les parties prenantes dont Alstom
et SNCF qui sont au minimum des
acheteurs importants qui doivent
s'engager et c'est vrai qu'à la demande
de Sophie Binet à la demande de la CGT
j'ai organisé cette table rond qui
réunira Xavier Bertrand les
représentants des entreprises en
question les représentants de la CGT de
manière à voir si et comment Alstom et
la SNCF peuvent nous aider dans ce
processus nous travaillons d' rchepied
monsieur le député nous allons continuer
à le faire jusqu'au bout et nous
trouvons une solution merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
récemment au syndicat vous avez dit on
ne gagne pas tous les combats j'ai envie
de vous dire encore faut-il les mener je
vousci parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
bricou pour le
[Applaudissements]
groupeot merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre en charge des des comptes
publics monsieur le ministre vous ne
savez plus où taper en matière
d'austérité budgétaire vous êtes vous
attaquez maintenant aux chambres des
métiers qui gère nos centrre de
formation des apprentis dans le texte
initial vous nous proposez deux mesures
qui les privent de moyens d'abord une
ponction de 29 millions sur les
cotisations des artisans ce qu'on
appelle la taxe affectée et une moindre
participation sur la prise en charge des
apprentis du coup pour faire face à
cette aostérité budgétaire la Direction
nationale des chambres des métiers
menace de fermer les plus petits centres
de formation dont celui de La Capelle
dans ma circonscription j'ai deux
questions monsieur le ministre
allez-vous prendre en compte et
confirmer dans l'hémicycle notre volonté
d'atténuer la pression sur les chambre
de métier comme l'un moment qui a été
voté en commission de finances
allez-vous raisonner la gouvernance des
chambres de métiers simplement pour leur
dire on ne joue pas avec la ruralité on
ne touche pas nos outils de formation de
proximité indispensable d'une part à
notre jeunesse en mal de mobilité mais
indispensable aussi à nos artisans en
mal de recrutement fermer un centre
d'apprentis comme celui de La Capelle
dans ma circonscription c'est mettre
plus de 250 jeunes désœuvrés à la rue
nos jeunes chez nous nos jeunes
choisissent souvent leur avenir au
regard de l'offre de proximité des
formations vous devez comprendre cette
réalité rurale merci de votre soutien
monsieur le ministre bravo je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à madame Carole Grandjean ministre en
charge de l'enseignement et de la
formation
professionnelle merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
bricou comme vous nous pensons que
l'apprentissage est une voie de
formation favorable aux jeunes et à leur
avenir qui d'ailleurs a participé à
lutter contre le chômage des jeunes
c'est une des grandes fiertés du
gouvernement une des mesures sur lequell
le gouvernement a réussi à installer une
politique publique d'envergure en ayant
fait un choix fort qui était celui de
promouvoir l'apprentissage d'y mettre
effectivement des dispositions
juridiques et de moyens permettant son
essort comme jamais et pour cause depuis
2018 nous sommes passés de 1000 à 3500
centres de formation par apprentissage
et nous avons trois fois plus
d'apprentis qu'il y a 5 ans c'est dire
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement nous avons
depuis cette rentrée plus de 900000
apprentis nouveaux apprentis qui sont
entrés en centre de formation par
apprentissage et nous avons l'objectif
d'aller vers un million d'apprentis qui
chaque année entre en formation par
apprentissage cet objectif qui est le
nôtre il est au fond assez simple il est
d'accompagner une un modèle de
financement qui accompagne justement les
dépenses engagées accompagner un juste
niveau de financement tout en prévenant
le risque de marge excessif opéré par
certains organismes de formation or nous
l'avons constaté l'existence d'écart
encore important entre certaines pour
certaines certifications entre les
niveaux de prise en charge et les coûts
réels engagés par les organismes de
formation sont observés il s'agit donc
pour nous d'engager une démarche de
Juste Prix en responsabilité avec nos
finances publiques pour autant le
gouvernement n'est pas euh aveugle aux
difficultés qui que peuvent rencontrer
certains petits CFA et je le rappelle
nous avons pour cette raison dans la loi
de 2018 octroyer des moyens aux régions
138 millions d'euros qui servent à
majorer les niveaux de prise en charge
pour maintenir dans les territoires une
offre de formation de proximité et de
qualité et 180 millions d'euros pour
soutenir les investissements c'est dire
monsieur le député que comme vous nous
sommes attachés à la compomagnement
cette centre de formation merci beaucoup
madame la ministre monsieur Briou madame
la ministre vous répondez pas
complètement ma question et vous
répondez pas surtout au besoins de
proximité des formations pour la
jeunesse sur nos territoires ruraux euh
je crois que c'est c'est des c'est des
crédits qu'il faut absolument
sauvegarder d'autres pistes sont
possibles d'ailleurs en matière
d'économie pour renforcer les crédits
vers ces vers ces centres de proximité
d'une part mieux répartir les budgets
sur les territoires en tenant compte
plus plus franchement de leurs besoins
et en tenant compte du coup des
spécificités des formations qui sont
dispensées et d'autre part en
mutualisant peut-être certaines dépenses
communes aux Chambres Consulaires
notamment entre les CCI et les CMA merci
beaucoup monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame Stéphanie cochert pour le
groupe
horizon merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
chargée des personnes handicapées madame
la ministre pilier des accords du sgure
de la santé du 13 juillet 2020 la prime
a permis une meilleure reconnaissance du
travail fourni par les acteurs de la
santé par une revalorisation de leur
salaire à hauteur de 183 € net par mois
cette revalorisation devait initialement
concerner uniquement les personnels
exerçant en milieu hospitalier elle a
finalement été étendue aux soignants des
secteurs sociaux et
médicau-sociaux les services généraux
des hôpitaux publics c'est-à-dire les
agents d'entretien ou de maintenance ont
eux aussi pu bénéficier d'une
augmentation de leur salaire le soutien
du G gouvernement ne s'arrête pas là les
personnels des épades ont eux aussi pu
bénéficier d'une augmentation de leur
salaire grâce à la mise en place de la
prime grand âge enfin début septembre
madame la Première ministre annoncé une
nouvelle revalorisation des prunes de
nuit des jours fériers et d'astreintte
pour les personnel des hôpitaux qui en
ont tant besoin ce sont des mesures
fortes et bienvenues pour ces secteurs
toutefois j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur le déséquilibre que ces
revalorisations créent avec d'autres
établissements médicauxsoaux qui n'en
bénéficient malheureusement pas c'est le
cas notamment des établissements du
secteur du handicap où la différence de
salaire avec des les personnels des
épades peut atteindre jusqu'à 300 € par
mois cela entraîne une fuite de certains
professionnels vers d'autres secteurs
plus rémunérateurs et rend la situation
encore plus difficile qu'elle ne l'est
déjà les établissements accueillant des
personnes atteintes d'un handicap
connaissent des situations similaires au
aux éepades les conditions de travail
sont difficiles
obligation de travailler tôt le matin et
tard le soir travail de nuit les
weekends et jour ferriers et les grilles
salariales restent inchangé depuis des
années madame la ministre nous devons
soutenir ce secteur et ne pas créer une
situation de concurrence entre des
métiers qui ont une même vocation
accompagneré dignement des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité ainsi ma
question est la suivante quelles mesures
concrètes le gouvernement envisage-t-il
en faveur de ces métiers qui sont
essentiels dans l'accompagnement des
plus ile d'entre nous merci beaucoup la
parole est à Madame Fadila katabi
ministre en charge des personnes
handicapées merci bien Madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée cochère je
vous remercie bien sûr pour cette cette
question combien cruciale qui porte en
fait sur l'attractivité l'attractivité
des métiers et qui constitue bien sûr
l'une des priorités pour le gouvernement
vous évoquer à juste titre bien sûr la
la la question des rémunérations et de
leur alignement dans les différents
secteurs en en particulier bien sûr pour
les nouvelles mesures que vous avez
évoqué concernant bien sûr le travail de
nuit les jours fériers et les astreintes
tout d'abord rappelons que ces mesures
sont déjà étendues je j'insiste
là-dessus à tous les établissements
public accueillant des personnes en
situation de handicap concernant et là
est le sujet les établissements privés
non lucratifs vous le savez peut-être
madame la députée des négociations sont
actuellement en cours entre les
partenaires sociaux pour parvenir à une
convention collective nationale unique
cette convention devra effectivement
concerner toute la branche je dis bien
toute la branche associative du secteur
sanitaire social et
médico-social concrètement nous
souhaitons avec la ministre des
solidarités et des familles que cette
convention permett de revaloriser les
salaires les plus bas d'améliorer bien
sûr la mobilité des professionnels et
plus largement de s'assurer que tous
soient bien couverts par une convention
protectrice et modernisée alors bien sûr
je suis certaine que dans le cadre de
ces discussions la question des
conditions de travail notamment bien sûr
des horaires est abordé bien sûr sur ces
sujets le gouvernement prendra toute sa
part de responsabilité comme nous
l'avons d'ailleurs toujours fait je me
permets de rappeler que le 1er juillet
2022 nous avons consacré 1 milliard je
dis bien 1 milliard d'euros à la
revalorisation des salaires des
professionnels concernés nous nous
connaissons tous le travail
effectivement qui est effectué au
quotidien pour accompagner les personnes
en situation de handicap ou encore les
personnes âgé aussi permettez-moi à
travers cette intervention de leur
rendre hommage merci merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Patrick Etzel pour le group
républicain merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche madame la ministre remment
nous nous sommes tous réjouis à
l'annonce des lauréat du prix Nobel de
physique puisque deux chercheurs
français furent primés et je tiens ici
une nouvelle fois à les en féliciter
très vivement toutefois il y a une
nombre au tableau lorsque vous regardez
les institutions où sont en poste nos
deux physiciens français le constat
était là sévère tous deux exercent dans
des universités étrangères et non pas
dans des institutions françaises de
recherche alors certes la recherche est
internationale mais la conséquence
directe c'est qu'une grande partie de la
renommée de ces prix Nobel retombe sur
des institutions étrangères et non pas
sur des institutions françaises et la
France ma question est donc simple
madame la ministre accepteriez-vous que
le combat pour le retour de nos
meilleurs chercheurs français dont les
prix Nobel et les médailles Fields
actuellement en poste à l'étranger soit
érigé en grande cause nationale en effet
il en va du futur de la performance de
notre recherche et de notre innovation
et donc par voie de conséquence du
devenir de la France je vous remercie je
vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sylvie rotaillot ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche merci madame la Présidente
messieurs mesdames les députés monsieur
le député
patrickzel d'abord je voudrais vraiment
vous remercier pour votre question qui
me permet d'abord aussi de rappeler non
seulement l'excellence de notre
recherche vous l'avez fait aussi mais de
nos formations et tout ce que aussi
cette majorité a fait j'en reparlerai
aussi pour l'attractivité de nos talents
et pour soutenir nos chercheurs alors à
travers eux cela nous permet de
maintenir effectivement la France vous
l'avez dit au rang de grandes nations
scientifiques et d'être le pays le plus
attractif en Europe en tout cas pour les
investissement en recherche et
développement notamment grâce au crédit
impô-recherche je vais répondre tout de
suite sur les prix Nobel je reviendrai
après sur quelques point d'attractivité
je voudrais dire que ces deux prix Nobel
physiciens français dont l'un a fait
toute sa carrière en France au CEA il
est parti à l'étranger à sa retraite
pour l'autre elle est partie elle l'a
dit pour des problématiqu ou en tout cas
des projets personnels et tous deux ont
eu cette récompense pour des
réalisations qu'ils ont fait au CEA
c'est-à-dire en France comme le prix
Nobel français de l'année dernière qui a
fait toute sa carrière en France et
encore aujourd'hui est en France dans
nos laboratoire alors je voudrais parler
aussi de la loi programmation pour la
recherche qui apporte une réponse
concrète au aussi aux rémunérations de
nos chercheurs et de tous ceux qui les
soutiennent et aussi des moyens
supplémentaires pour les projets pour
les infrastructures de recherche et
directement pour nos laboratoires et le
travail que l'on fait actuellement pour
la simplification au quotidien de la vie
de nos chercheurs pour redonner du temps
recherche je voudrais donner quelques
chiffres c'est une augmentation de 16 %
de la rémunération de nos doctorants
c'est une augmentation de 20 à 30 % de
la rémunération de nos jeunes chercheurs
c'est des chaires de profession junior
poste supplémentaire qui connaissent un
véritable succès puisque avec plus de
1000 candidats un/ers des lera
reviennent de l'étranger c'est aussi les
chair d'excellence en santé de avec un
financement de France 2030 qui
permettent d'attirer les meilleurs voilà
Monsieur député oui c'est une cause
importante pour nous et je suis d'accord
avec vous mer ministre monsieur le
député allez-y merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la ministre j'entends
bien mais ce qu'il faut vraiment noter
c'est que il y a 10 ans nous étions
encore en 5e place en terme de
participation aux publication mondial là
où aujourd'hui nous sommes passés en 10e
place la question de l'attractivité est
devenue beaucoup plus importante qu'elle
ne l'était précédemment et de toute
évidence les mesures que vous avez
prises restent insuffisantes et je
voudrais insister sur le fait que l'un
des deux prix Nobel de physique
justement a déclaré que il est allé à
l'étranger parce que hélas la France n'a
pas su créer les conditions lui
permettant de de poursuivre son activité
en France et c'est un problème récurrent
que nous avons aujourd'hui madame la
ministre vraiment il faut là aussi aller
plus loin mettre la démultiplier nous
avons des gens remarquables nous devons
aussi faire en sorte qu'ils reviennent
en France parce que il en va du
rayonnement et du développement de notre
activité merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Dominique potier pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente le
7 octobre nous avons sans ambiguïé
condamné le terrorisme du Hamas qui
ensanglanté le sud d'Israël 10 jours
après avec la même clarté nous alertons
sur la situation dramatique du peuple
palestinien à Gaza des civils meurent
sous les bombardements les enfants sont
les premières victimes des pénuries
celle des hôpitaux des médicaments de
l'énergie de l'eau et le Programme
alimentaire mondial nous dit qu'il reste
4 à 5 jours de nourriture dans les
territoires de Gaza les Palestiniens a
proclamé la présidente de la commission
européenne ne peuvent être payer le prix
de la barbarie du Hamas et nous ajoutons
que les Israéliens et la démocratie ne
peuvent succomber à l'idéologie de leurs
ennemis le groupe socialiste est clair
il affirme sa même solidarité avec le
peuple le droit du peuple israélien et
le droit du peuple palestinien notre
ligne est claire c'est celui du droit
humanitaire du droit international
chaque jour chaque viconte et un enfant
de AA à le même prix à la même vie la
même valeur qu'un enfant de Gaza chaque
jour chaque viconte et nous avons trois
questions à vous poser la première par
les airs par la mer par le sol égyptien
où on est la diplomatie française pour
faire avancer les couloirs humanitaire
la deuxème question tousse au
multilatéralismeisien quels sont les
amendements que porte la France
aujourd'hui pour faire triompher une
résolution au Conseil de sécurité celle
portée notamment par la puissance Brésil
en quels sont les amendements que porte
la France quelle est sa ligne
diplomatique et enfin et enfin dans
cette région qui a porté tant de sang et
tant d'espérance nous posons la question
de où on est la diplomatie française et
européenne pour faire naître l'esprit
d'un Schuman capable de faire travailler
ensemble le Liban la Jordanie Israël et
la Palestine pour créer un espace de
paix un chemin de paix qui est le chemin
du courage je vous remercie la parole
est à Madame chroula zacaropouo
secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement de la Francop des
partenariats
internationaux madame la Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés msieur
le députés Dominique
potier le président de la République et
la ministre ont multiplié comme vous
avez vu les essences depuis le début de
l'attaque terroriste soup par Israël
pour éviter un ébrasement
régional notre soutien à Israël ne
souffre de aucune ambigué visé par des
actes terroristes abdominal Israël a
subi une offensive s précédent de son
histoire la France se tient au côté
d'Israël et comme l'a dit la ministre
rien ne suffit les terrorisme jamais
Israël a le droit de se défendre la
ministre lors de son déplacement ces
derniers jours a rappelé que elle devait
le faire dans le respect du droit
international à préservant les
population civiles la France agit en ses
sens Carine colon a annoncé au c une
aide de 10 millions d'euros aux ENGAN
des Nations Unies et aux humanitaire au
bénéfice direct des population de Gaza
et plus largement l'aide doit pouvoir
entrer à Gaza une aide a été préparée
sous les Gide des Nations Unies avec les
contrôles ncessaire et doit pouvoir
passer il faut aussi que les civils qui
souhaitent sortir de Gaza puissent les
faire les Hamas doit cesser de les
empêcher soyez assurés messieur les
députés que les efforts de la France
poursuivre en particulier pour éviter
toute escalade régionale c'était aussi
une priorité de déplacement de la
ministre Colona au proch Orient hier et
avanthier merci merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Bartz pour le rassemblement
national merci madame la Présidente
chers collègue ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Marc fen ministre d'agriculture
monsieur le ministre alors que les
vendanges touchent à leur fin le constat
est clair la viticulture française est
en train de mourir baisse de la
consommation de 20in de 70 % en 60 ans
aléa climatique manque de réserve d'eau
et dénigrement de nos vticulteurs comme
le font certains députés d'extrême
gauche présents dans cet hémicycle
explique entre autres les difficultés de
ce secteur qui représente près de 500000
emplois sur le territoire national et
incarne l'art de vivre à la française la
catastrophe est économique mais aussi
humaine je vous ai déjà alerté à
plusieurs reprises monsieur le ministre
au travers de courrier mais peu de
mesures concrètes ont été prises le 26
juillet 2022 j'affirmé à Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire que la cocote minute était
pleine qu' elle allait vous péter à la
figure un an plus tard cette phrase est
encore plus d'actualité chez moi dans
l'ode la véticulture est avec le
touriste tourisme pardon le principal
secteur de l'économie les viticulteurs
au Doig sont à bout et ils ne se
laisseront pas faire de nombreuses
actions violentes vont avoir lieu et ont
déjà commencé il y a quelques jours le
Comité d'action viticole a tenté de
mettre le feu à un négoce à Sal d'udde
où un drame a été évité de justesse nous
devons tout faire pour éviter que le r
le bol de la profession que nous
comprenons ne se dégénéralise en
violence si aucune mesure n'est prise je
crains que les viticulteurs qui n'auront
plus rien à perdre deviennent
incontrôlable et ne mettent le fau au
département de l'ude monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple que
comptez-vous faire pour sauver
rapidement la viticulture je vous la
viticulture française je vous le répète
rapidement monsieur le ministre
je je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Marc fenau ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire oui merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député bartè merci
merci de votre question d'abord aucune
violence n'est acceptable et je ne
voudrais pas que nous accréditions ici
la tèse qui pourrait être acceptable
j'ai en tout cas pas entendu l'inverse
dans vos propos que d'exprimer sa
colollère y compris sa détresse par la
violence et donc on doit à toute fin les
uns et les autres comme responsables
publics locaux et nationaux faire en
sorte d'essayer de trouver les voies de
l'apaisement deuxième éléement vous n
demandez ce qu'on fait sur la
viticulture d'abord vous rappelez que
nous avons agi continuement et qu' le
gouvernement depuis 3 ou 4 ans a été au
rendez-vous malheureusement des crises
conjoncturel devenu structurel un
milliard sur le gel plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros sur d'autres
dispositifs sur l'au en particulier nous
avons agi dès cette année pour faire
face à un épisode supplémentaire qui est
l'épisode de la sécheresse et nous avons
besoin d'accompagner c'est les le
le l'exonération des charges sociales de
la MSA 1,4 million d'euros c'est la
distillation pour retirer des volumes et
pour faire en sorte que les coûts
remontent en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
espère c'est près de 30 millions d'euros
c'est concret c'est pour l'Aure c'est ce
ne sont que les montants de l'au dont je
je me fais l'écho et puis nous avons
besoin maintenant travailler sur les
questions de sécheresse on va documenter
maintenant j'en parle beaucoup avec les
professionnels de l'ude les pertes qui
sont lié à la sécheresse cette année on
les aura au moment de les déclarations
de récolte vous le savez comme moi et à
ce momentlà on regardera ce qui est pris
en charge par les assurances et les
autres difficultés pourra moner les
viticulteur et puis je le dis il faut
qu'on se projette au-delà de l'année
2023 24 et les années suivantes pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait encore une
agriculture et qu'il y ait
singulièrement encore une viticulture
dans l'eau et dans toute cette région
c'est les sujets d'accès à l'eau c'est
les sujets de résilience c'est les
sujets de d'évolution des ensépagements
pour faire en sorte que les viticulteurs
trouvent un avenir et pas seulement des
solutions dans les les moyens de crise
que nous déployons au fur et à
mesure je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre monsieur le député le problème
de l'eau doit être réglé rapidement
monsieur le ministre comme vous avez dit
le 4 mars 1976 à Montredon les Corbières
dans l' d'un viticulteur un policier
avait perdu la vie lors de ces
manifestations nous avons tout faire
pour éviter de nouveaux drames nous
devons travailler tous ensemble dans un
seul bus sauver la viticulture française
et celle de l'OD en particulier mais
rapidement monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie la séance des questions
gouvernement est terminée la séance est
suspendue pour une durée de 10 minutes
et nous reprendrons sur le vote solennel
sur le projet de loi visant à sécuriser
et réguler l'espace numérique y